BEEN NO GOOD MORNING I'M GOING
TO GET STARTED AS A SUB
COMMITTEE. AND- TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO WELCOME
EVERYONE. AS YOU ALL KNOW AS WE
START THE- HEARINGS WE'VE
GOTTEN NICE SEVERAL.
HOUSEKEEPING RULES IF WE HAVE
TO GO OVER FOR ALL START WITH
THAT AND HOPE ON THAT AS WE DO
THAT COUPLE MEMBERS WILL COME
DOWN AND- AND AS WELL AS- BILL
AUTHORS. BUT I WILL WELCOME
EVERYONE CALL THE- TO ORDER THE
HEARING FOR THE ASSEMBLY WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE COMMITTEE
BEFORE WE BEGIN I'LL GO OVER
PRECAUTIONS THE ASSEMBLY IS
TAKING TO PROTECT THE HEALTH OF
OUR STAFF AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC FIRST EVERYONE IN THE
CAPITAL MUST WEAR A MASK. THIS
INCLUDES HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A
MASK WE CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU
TO ENSURE MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA
AND THE PUBLIC HAVE ACCESS TO
OUR PROCEEDINGS TODAY THERE ARE
MULTIPLE WAYS TO OBSERVE AND
PARTICIPATE IN THIS HEARING.
TESTIMONY CAN BE PROVIDED IN
PERSON HERE IN THE- HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM VIA THE PHONE OR
VIA. VIDEO CONFERENCE. AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
LOCATED AT THE NORTH STEPS OF
THE CAPITOL WE ALSO ACCEPT
WRITTEN TESTIMONY. THROUGH THE
COMMITTEE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL. REACH BILL WE ARE
ALLOWING UP TO ME WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND TO ME WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THESE WITNESSES HAVE
BEEN MADE KNOWN TO THE
COMMITTEE IN ADVANCE. OF THE
HEARING IN ADDITIONAL. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ONLY. IF A WITNESS
PREFERS TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
VIA VIDEO CONFERENCE OR IS
UNABLE TO ENTER THE CAPITAL.
THE TO THE CAPACITY LIMIT A
WITNESS. MAY PROVIDE TESTIMONY
AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
LOCATED AT THE NORTH STEPS OF
THE CAPITOL. WE WILL AGAIN BE
USING MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANYONE
CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL. CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING. IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
PIN NUMBER IS TWO FOUR TWO SIX
TWO THREE SEVEN. AGAIN THAT
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
AND THE PAIN IS. TWO FOUR TWO
SIX TWO THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN.
PLEASE CALL WHEN THE AUTHOR THE
BILL YOU PLANT IS TESTIFIED. IS
ON. BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION IF YOU ARE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH MODERATOR
PHONE SERVICE. YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE SIX. I
COMMITTEE STAFF WILL BE THERE
TO TRY TO HELP. WE MEMBERS IF
YOU'D LIKE TO RESPOND TO A ROLL
CALL. ASK A QUESTION PROVIDE
COMMENT PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND
TO GET OUR ATTENTION AND REYES
MICROPHONE WHEN IT IS YOUR TURN
TO SPEAK.TO PRESENT A BILL TO
THE COMMITTEE PLEASE PRESENT
FOR THE MICROPHONE AT THE REAR
CHAMBER. GEN UPDATE S. B. FOUR
SIX THREE HAS BEEN PULLED BY
THE AUTHOR. LOCALLY WE HAVE A
QUORUM YEAH IT'S A LITTLE HANG
TIGHT. WITH THAT WE DO HAVE A
HANDFUL OF BILLS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DOES B. TWO SIX SIX TO
SIX EIGHT. FOUR NINE SIX SEVEN
ONE SIX AND A TWO ONE WILL PICK
THOSE UP WHEN TIME IS RIGHT- I
DON'T QUESTIONS SEE ANYONE
ASKING QUESTIONS THERE WILL
TAKE THE ROLE AGAIN WHEN WE
HAVE- A QUORUM. DISRUPTIONS I
THINK EVERYONE IS AWARE THAT WE
HAVE THE DISCRETION TO BRING
ATTENTION TO THE MATTER WE ALSO
HAVE THE SERGEANTS HERE WHO.
CAN AND WILL REMOVE FOLKS DO
TO- ANY DISRUPTIONS- THAT
IMPEDES ON THE HEARING SEOUL
PLEASE- BE AWARE OF THAT. WITH
THAT- WE DO HAVE ONE AUTHOR
HERE AND THAT IS- MISS-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEANS REVERSE
AJ ARE FIVE AND SO- WE DO HAVE
A- RECOMMENDATION OF SUPPORT.
TO DO THAT SHE DOES HAVE TWO
WITNESSES THAT WILL BE-TESTIFYING- WILL ASK IF SHE
WANTS TO COME FORWARD AND
PRESENT A DR FIVE WE ARE AGAIN
IN THE SUB COMMITTEE SO WE
WON'T BE ABLE TO TAKE ACTION SO
WE HAVE A QUORUM PLEASE PROCEED
WITH YOUR PRESENTATION. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT AJ ARE FIVE
THAT I'M JOINT OFFERING WITH
ASSEMBLY MINORITY LEADER MARIE
WALDRON. THIS WITH THE
RESOLUTION BEFORE YOU
COMMEMORATES THE FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE WILD FREE
ROAMING HORSES AND BURROS ACT
OF NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE. IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE STIPULATION
OF THIS ACT. TO PROTECT WILD
HORSES AND BURROS AJ ARE FIVE
ALSO CALLS FOR A TEMPORARY
MORATORIUM ON HORSE ROUNDUPS
WITH THE INTENTION OF
RESTORING. A THRIVING
ECOLOGICAL BALANCE IN
CALIFORNIA TO SUPPORT THE
STATE'S BIO DIVERSITY GOALS AND
DETERMINE BEST PRACTICES FOR
ACHIEVING THAT BALANCE. WILD
HORSES AND BURROS ARE AN
INTEGRAL PART OF CALIFORNIA'S.
MAJESTIC NATURAL SCENERY
HOWEVER THE FEDERAL BUREAU OF
LAND MANAGEMENT. IS DECEMBER
DISSEMINATING WILD HORSE AND
BURRO POPULATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
THROUGH EXCESSIVE ROUNDUPS.
THESE ROUNDUPS ARE CARRIED OUT
USING HELICOPTERS WHICH OFTEN
RESULTS AND SEPARATED HERDS AND
THE DEATH AND INJURY OF
MULTIPLE HORSES. ONCE THE
HORSES ARE ROUNDED UP THEY ARE
LOCKED UP IN A CORRAL AND SOLD
OFF FOR AS LITTLE AS A DOLLAR A
DAY AND THE BUREAU OF LAND
MANAGEMENT'S ADOPTION PROGRAM
IS EVEN PAYING A THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR INDIVIDUALS. TO
TAKE THE HORSES WITHOUT ANY
SIGNIFICANT OVERSIGHT. THE NEW
YORK TIMES INVESTIGATION DONE
EARLIER THIS YEAR FOUND THAT
CAPTURED WILD HORSES ARE SOLD
OFF. AND OFTEN END UP IN
SLAUGHTER HOUSES IN CANADA AND
MEXICO. IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT CALIFORNIA VOTERS
OVERWHELM OVERWHELMINGLY
APPROVED PROPOSITION SIX WHICH
PROHIBITED THE SELLING OF
CALIFORNIA WILD HORSES. TO OUT
OF STATE SLAUGHTER HOUSES AND
YET MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS
LATER. WE ARE FAILING TO
RESPECT THE VOTERS WELL. TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
TODAY. I HAVE RENEE ROWLAND
CHAIR OF POP PACK AND JESSICA
JOHNSTON AN ENVIRONMENTAL
SCIENTIST. THANK YOU FOR THAT
THANK YOU SOME EVER BEFORE WE
GO ON TO YOUR WITNESSES WERE
GOING TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM WE
HAVE- HAVE. OUR MEMBERS HERE SO
MY SECRETARY. EDUARDO GARCIA
PRESIDENT DOLLY BENNETT BIGELOW
FRIEDMAN CRISTINA GARCIA KALRA
LEVINE MURATSUCHI NOLAN RUBIO
SALAS SMITH THE A PADUCAH. WARD.
THANK YOU ARE WILL PROCEED WITH
YOUR TWO WITNESSES- TWO MINUTES
FOR YOUR WITNESSES. MODERATOR
PLEASE. WHEN A ROLAND YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU CARE GARCIA
BYE GALLEON NUMBERS I'M READY
ROLAND ON BEHALF OF POP PACK.
IN ADDITION TO COMMEMORATING
THIS HISTORIC ACT HR FIVE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER ON
BIODIVERSITY. WHILE BOARD
MEMBER AT THEIR SCORCHED PART
OF THAT DIVERSITY THEY'RE
ACTUALLY WILDLIFE.
OVERPOPULATION IS A FALSE
NARRATIVE BY OUR FEDERAL
AGENCIES WHO REDUCED THE LAND
AREAS TO HALF THEIR SIDE. TO
CLEAR 90% OF PUBLIC LANDS FOR
FOSSIL FUEL EXTRACTIVE
INDUSTRIES. NOW THE TARGET
POPULATIONS ARE SET TO THE SAME-LOW NUMBER AS IT WAS BACK IN
SEVENTY ONE WHEN IT WAS A
CRISIS. BUT I'M HERE TO THINK
THERE'S NOT AN OVERPOPULATION.
THERE TOO LITTLE LAND. THE
ALARM HAS A LIMIT OF TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED HORSES BROKE FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE THAT HALF TO ONE
THIRD THE SIZE OF OUR THREATENS
MOUNTAIN LION POPULATION. TOP
PACKAGE NOT A VOICE IN THE
WILDERNESS ON THIS THERE'S A
PUBLIC OUTCRY ACROSS THE NATION
TO STOP THESE ROUNDUPS.
THOUSANDS OF WRITTEN A LETTER
TO SECRETARY HOLLAND THERE'S
PROTESTS IN UTAH AND NEVADA.
HERE CLUB HAS UP FOR LIVESTOCK
TO BE ELIMINATED FROM THE WILD
HORSE BROKE AREA. BECAUSE OF
LAND DEGRADATION AND WESTERN
WATERSHEDS IS CALLED FOR
LIVESTOCK TO BE COMPLETELY
REMOVED FROM THE LAND. WELL THE
ELEVEN ISSUED FOR THE ADOPTION
TO WATER PROGRAM. AND THAT
WOULD LEAD OF COURSE FIRE BORN
FORMER AG EXHIBIT THE FEDEX.
MINORITY LEADER WALDRON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LORENA HAD NO
WITH SIXTY FOUR MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS. WE HAVE THE OLD
STANDARD OF CONSERVING 30% OF
LAND WATERS. AND WE'RE CALLING
FOR A STOP TO THIS FOR
CALIFORNIA TO USE IT STRONG
VOICE. FOR A DRIVING ECOLOGICAL
BALANCE ON OUR LAND FOR THE
BIODIVERSITY THAT MUST BE
PRESERVED AND TO DIVEST OF
THESE INDUSTRIES THAT ARE
DRIVING THE CLIMATE CRISIS. AND
THE SIXTH MASS EXTINCTION OF
SPEECHES. IN THE HISTORY OF THE
PLANET. AND WE ARE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS UP WHAT THIS IS JESSICA
JOHNSON AND SHE'S ALSO ON THE
TELEPHONE. OKAY THANK YOU ARE
FIRST I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE FOR
CONSIDERATION AND YOUR SUPPORT
OF A J. R. FIVE. AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JESSICA
JOHNSON AND I HOLD A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN ENVIRONMENTAL STUDIES.
I'VE SPENT SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF TIME VISITING AND STUDYING
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA'S HIGH
DESERT ECOSYSTEMS AND THE
RELATED COMPLEX WILD HORSES AND
BURROS ON PUBLIC LANDS. THIS
RESOLUTION PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HOLD PUBLIC LAND
MANAGERS ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
PROTECTION OF OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES. BIODIVERSITY AND
ECOSYSTEMS IN CALIFORNIA
CONSISTENT WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER AN EIGHTY TWO
TWENTY. AS A REMINDER IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE WILD
HORSES AND BURROS ARE PROTECTED
BY FEDERAL LAW AND THE NATIONAL
HERITAGE ET YOUR THE CONCERNS
THAT WILD HORSES AND BURROS
WERE DISAPPEARING FROM FEDERAL
PUBLIC LANDS. AT THAT TIME
CONGRESS UNANIMOUSLY PASSED THE
WILD FREE ROAMING HORSES AND
BURROS ACT. THE ACT DECLARED
THAT WILD FREE ROAMING HORSES
AND BURROS ARE LIVING BEEN BOLD
OF THE HISTORIC AND PIONEER
SPIRIT OF THE WET. THAT THEY
CONTRIBUTE TO THE DIVERSITY OF
LIFE FORMS WITHIN THE NATION
AND ENRICH THE LIVES OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE. AND THAT THESE
COURSES IN BOROUGHS ARE FAST
DISAPPEARING FROM THE AMERICAN
TEAM. IT IS THE POLICY OF
CONGRESS THAT THE WILD FREE
ROAMING HORSES AND BURROS SHALL
BE PROTECTED FROM CAPTURE
BRANDING HARASSMENT. OR DEATH
AND YOUR ACCOMPLISHMENTS THERE
TO BE CONSIDERED IN THE AREA
WHERE PRESENTLY FOUND AS AN
INTEGRAL PART OF THE NATURAL
SYSTEM ON PUBLIC LANDS. WHAT
WE'RE ASKING HERE IS FOR
CALIFORNIA TO LEAD THE WAY TO
ENSURE THAT THE CURRENT
SCIENTIFIC PRINCIPLES ARE BEING
APPLIED UNDER THE EXISTING WILD
FREE ROAMING HORSES AND BURROS
ACT. AND WE RETHINK OUR ROLE IN
PROTECTING OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES AND BIODIVERSITY
WITHIN CALIFORNIA'S BOUNDARIES.
WHICH INCLUDES OUR WILD HORSES
AND BURROS. AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION TODAY AS WE
LEAVE NO STONE UNTURNED AS WE
NAVIGATE OUR PROTECTION FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND BIODIVERSITY ON
OUR PUBLIC LANDS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AT THIS
TIME ALL ASKED TO SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY OTHER- INDIVIDUALS
WANTING TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL THAT ARE HERE. IN THE
CHAMBERS. I SEE NO ONE COME
FORWARD ALL EYES TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE- IN THE
TELECONFERENCE ROOM. OKAY NO
ONE COMING FORWARD. MODERATOR
ARE THERE ANY OTHER INDIVIDUALS
ON THE TELEPHONE LINES WHILE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF A
J. R. FIVE. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF A J. R. FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO
THERE IS NO ONE TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AJ ARE FIVE THANK
YOU I DON'T HAVE ANYONE LISTED
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION- ALL
ASK UP TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
IN THE CHAMBER TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. NO ONE COMING
FORWARD ANYONE IN THE
TELECONFERENCE ROOM. NO ONE-
ANYONE ON THE TELEPHONE LINE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. COMMENTED
IN OPPOSITION TO H. A R. FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE MIN ZERO. WE
HAVE NONE TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO A TERRIFIED. OKAY
PLEASE. THE DISAIT THERE ARE
TURNOUT BY I'M SORRY NONE NOW
THERE THERE ARE NO OKAY NO ONE
THANK CONTACTED FOR
CLARIFICATION- ALL RIGHT WELL
BRING IT BACK TO- THE FLOOR
HERE ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OR IS A OKAY WE HAVE A
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS REMARKS
VICE CHAIR. FIND US ON OF MINE
IT'S NOT A QUESTION IS- MORE
I'LL BE OPPOSING THIS TODAY- IS
A VERY SERIOUS ISSUE IN MY
DISTRICT SPECIFICALLY IN THE
DEVIL'S GARDEN REGION OF MODOC
COUNTY. AND THE REALITY IS
THESE ARE WILD HORSES AND
BURROS ARE NOT NATIVE. TO MY
REGION AND THEY ACT AS AN
INVASIVE SPECIES IN THE
ECOSYSTEM OF DEVIL'S GARDEN. SO
I'M CURRENTLY THE HERD
POPULATION IS ROUGHLY A HUNDRED
AND 50% ABOVE THE SUSTAINABLE.
SUSTAINABLE FOR THAT LANDSCAPE
THE OVER POPULATION- RESULT IN
LACK OF VEGETATION AND GRAZING
ON WATER AND LEAVE THESE
ANIMALS MOUNT NEW MALAMUTE.
NISH NOURISHED ACCUSE ME AND
SICKLY. AND THE GATHERS- THEY
BRING THE HORSES TOGETHER
THEY'RE ABLE TO VACCINATE THEM
A PROPER MEDIC MEDICAL CARE
THAT THEY NEED. AND IT PREVENTS
DISEASE AND DEATH- SO. ALTHOUGH
RESPECTFULLY I LISTEN TO THE
TESTIMONY THAT IS NOT THE CASE
IN MY REGION. AND ACTUALLY THE
DESTRUCTION OF THE VEGETATION
IS IN VACCINE THE SAGE GROUSE
AND OTHER- THINGS IN OUR ECO
SYSTEM SO TODAY I'M GOING TO-
BE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSING. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. TOMORROW
CERVANTES SUMMER FOR ME. THANK
YOU IRATE I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AND I YOU KNOW I PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA BEEN VERY CLEAR THAT
THEY DON'T WANT TO SEE. HORSES
PICKED UP- SOLD OFF AND THEN A
YEAR LATER RESOLD AND SENT TO
SLAUGHTER. I DO THINK THAT-
VICE CHAIR DOLLY RAISES
IMPORTANT POINTS ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT ANIMALS CAN BE PICKED
UP IF THEY'RE SICK IF THEY
CONVERT WE NEED A VETERINARY
CARE AND IF THERE REALLY ARE
WAYS OF. RE HOMING THEM THAT
WILL GIVE THEM A BETER CHANCE
OF LIFE AND I JUST HOPE AS THIS
I'M GONNA SUPPORT THIS TODAY.
BUT AS THIS MOVES FORWARD AS A
HORSE OWNER MYSELF AND SOMEONE
WHO'S A LITTLE BIT FAMILIAR
WITH THIS ISSUE FOR ME JUST
YEARS OF HEARING DEBATE ABOUT
THIS IN THE HORSE COMMUNITY. I
THINK THERE ARE SOME REAL
ISSUES TO ADDRESS FOR THE
WELFARE OF THESE ANIMALS AND I
JUST HOPE THAT YOU'RE OPEN TO
TAKING AMENDMENTS AS THIS MOVES
FORWARD- TO. ADDRESS YOU KNOW
SOME REALLY LEGITIMATE CONCERNS
AND ALSO ALLOWING. WE HOPE AND
HOMING OF SOME OF THESE ANIMALS
THAT CAN LEAD TO A MUCH BETTER
LIFE FOR THEM ULTIMATELY. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. WE'D WE DO NEED A
MOTION AND A SECOND TO HAVE A
MOTION BY. THE MEMBER KALRA A
SECOND BUT SOME MEMBER RUBIO.
ANOTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
OF MOVED TO THE AUTHOR YOU WANT
TO CLOSE. AND THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE
ALL RIGHT SEEING IF THERE'S A
MOTION AND SECOND THERE IS. TO
PASS RECOMMENDATION- SECRETARY
FOR HIS FELLOW. THE MOTION IS
BE ADOPTED EDUARDO GARCIA HI.
EDUARDO GARCIA I DOLLY NO DOLLY
NO BENNETT. SENATE I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW KNOWN FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
I CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA
GARCIA I KALRA KALRA I. LEVINE
LEVINE I MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI
I KNOW IN. NO WIN NO RUBIO
RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS ICE SMITH.
VIPTELA WARD MORE DIE. IN. FOUR
THIRTY WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
ANY OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON
WILL MOVE ON TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR VERY QUICKLY WE HAVE A
FEW ITEMS THERE IS 266-684-9671
SIX EIGHT TWO ONE CAN I GET A
MOTION TO MOVE THAT WE HAVE
MOTION BY MIDDLE OF SECOND
WOMEN'S GARCIA SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. EDUARDO GARCIA
HI EDUARDO GARCIA AYE DOLLY.
AYE DOLLY AYE BENNETT. BIGELOW
BIGELOW I FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN HI
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I KALRA. KALRA HI LEVINE LEVINE
AYE MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I
KNOW WHEN AND WHEN I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS I SMITH
SMITH I. VIA PADURA. WARD WORD
I. ARTICULATE THAT OPEN FOR THE
MEMBERS HAD ON WILL GOING TO
HAVE TO IS SENATE BILL EIGHTY
BY MISTER MCGUIRE IS HERE.
PLEASE- RECEIVE WE DO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES THAT WILL BE SPEAKING.
AND SUPPORT IN ONE TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE LET. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR IN
GOOD- AFTERNOON MEMBERS NOT A
VICE YEAR IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU
AT THE JOINT COMMITTEES ON
FISHERIES AND AQUACULTURE WORKS
WITH THE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
HARD WORKING INDIVIDUALS OF THE
GOLDEN STATE'S COMMERCIAL AND
RECREATIONAL FISHING FLEETS AND
ADVANCES IN ON THIS BILL EVERY
FEW YEARS TO BE A REMEDY ISSUES
AND CHALLENGES LARGE AND SMALL.
THAT WE ASK FOLKS TO BE A TO-COME OUT OF HER SHELL IF YOU
WILL- SB EIGHTY ADDRESSES
VARIOUS ISSUES INCLUDING
EXTENDING CRAB SEASON PRESO
PERIOD TO ADDRESS SAFETY
CONCERNS FOR FISHERMEN ALLOWING
FOR CRAB FISHERY SHIN OPTIONS
DUE TO THE PRESENCE OF THE MILK
ASSET ALLOWING THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO COLLECT BIOLOGICAL
SAMPLES FROM COMMERCIAL
FISHERIES. I STREAMLINED THE
TRANSFER OF THE DUNGEONS CRAB
DESSEL PERMIT UPON THE SAILING
OF PLIES- IN FOCUS ON ALL FAIR
START DELAYS ASSOCIATE THE RISK
ASSESSMENT MITIGATION PROGRAM A
WEEK AFFECTIONATELY CALLED RAMP
IN ORDER TO REDUCE THE RISK OF
MARINE LIFE ENTITLEMENT WHICH I
GOTTA SAY RESEARCHERS BEEN
INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL NEARLY
ALL THESE RECOMMENDATIONS CAME
TO US FROM THE DUNGEON THIS
CRAP TASK FORCE. NOW THAT TASK
FORCE IS LEGISLATIVELY MANDATED
AS AN ADVISORY BODY- AND THEY
ARE TASKED WITH REVIEWING AND
EVALUATING THE CRAB FISHERY
MANAGEMENT MEASURES IN
PROVIDING THERE ARE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE IN THE JOINT
COMMITTEE ON FISHERIES AND
AQUACULTURE IN THE FISH AND
GAME COMMISSION- AND SO WE HAVE
THIS ON THEM THIS BILL HERE AND
I WANT TO SHARE THAT. ON THE
ISSUE OF THE FAIR START DELAY
ASSOCIATED WITH THE RAMP THAT
RECOMMENDATION COMMITTEE VOTED
SEVENTEEN TO THREE BETTER BRING
THIS FORWARD WHICH IS WHY WE
HAVE IT IN OUR ON THIS BILL ON
THE LINE TODAY WE HAVE MIKE
CONROY THE EXACTLY DIRECTOR OF
THE PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATION AND
LUCAS FREAKS THE THAT FOR
EXCUSE ME WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
FOR THE TIME STRUCTURE. THANK
YOU. BUILDERS HAVE A SUPPORT
RACHAEL WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES.
MIKE CONROY PACIFIC COAST
FEDERATION. THE MOTION SIR. WE
HAVE WITNESSES BE A TELL- THIS
MODERATE. HOW BOTH- TEST FIRES
WE ARE OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
CONROY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
YOU CAN HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR
YOU PLEASED TO SEE. PERFECT
THANK YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
NUMBER- MY NAME IS MIKE FOUNDER
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION A
ASSOCIATION. HERE TODAY
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL EIGHTY. THIS BILL WOULD
IMPROVE SAFETY OF COMMERCIAL
FISHING OPERATIONS AT SEA BY
ALLOWING TENSION IS CRAFTED
FROM TO SET THEIR GEAR SIXTY
FOUR HOURS BEFORE THE OPENING
OF THE SEASON. IT WOULD ALSO
IMPROVE THE INTEGRITY OF THE
SEAFOOD SUPPLY CHAIN BY
ALLOWING OUR STATE AGENCIES
PERSONAL IN THIS VERY SHARP AND
DUNGENESS CRAB. AS YOU KNOW IN
ADDITION TO THE HARDSHIPS%
FISHERMEN FACED IN RESPONDING
TO THE CALL THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THE COMMERCIAL
FISHERY IS A PROPER STATE HAVE
BEEN DEALING WITH SIGNIFICANT
ECONOMIC AND REGULATORY
HARDSHIPS IN THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS. WITH THE LOSS OF
MULTIPLE FISHING VESSELS ON THE
WEST COAST IN RECENT YEARS
TAKING ACTIONS THAT CAN IMPROVE
SAFETY FOR BOTH BAFFLED AND
CREW IS PARAMOUNT. AND
INCREASED PRESO PERIOD FOR THE
DUNGENESS CRAB FISHERY IN THE
CENTRAL COAST OF CALIFORNIA
WILL ENSURE THAT FISHERMEN ARE
AFFORDED THE FLEXIBILITY TO
DEPLOY THEIR GEAR IN RESPONSE
TO VARIABLE WEATHER CONDITIONS.
DISTINCT CREASE FLEXIBILITY
ROOM FOR IMPROVED SAFETY AND
COULD EVEN SAVE LIVES. SB
EIGHTY PROVIDES SOLUTIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN VETTED AND
RECOMMENDED TO US BY THE
DUNGENESS CRAB TASK FORCE A
LEGISLATIVELY MANDATED BODY.
CAPTURED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
THE BILL GREATLY BENEFITS
SESSION BECAUSE IT PROVIDES THE
FLEXIBILITY CONSISTENCY AND
SAFETY THEY NEED IT IS ALSO
PROBABLY SUPPORTED BY BOTH THE
INDUSTRY AND VARIOUS
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THEIR AYE VOTE
ON SB EIGHTY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OUR NEXT SPEAKER. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS LUCAS BURKE AND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHTY. OVER THE LAST
FIVE YEARS WE HAVE PARTNERED
CLOSELY WITH COMMERCIAL
DUNGENESS CRAB FISHERMEN
INCLUDING SUPPORTING- THEN
PARTICIPATION THE DUCHESS CRAP
TASK FORCE. THE ONGOING SUPPORT
OF THIS COOPERATIVE BODIES
CRITICAL INCLUDING THIS BILL
MOVING FORWARD THE TASK FORCE'S
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ENABLE THE
DEVELOPMENT ADMINISTRATION
OPTION IN ITS SAMPLING
REQUIREMENT. INCREASES AND
OCCURRENCE AND SEVERITY OF
ELEVATED DOMOIC ACID LEVELS IS
ONE OF THE MANY CLIMATE DRIVEN
OCEAN CHANGES IMPACTING
FISHERIES AND ECOSYSTEMS THEY
DEPEND ON. IF THE RATIO OPTION
WILL GIVE MANAGERS THE ABILITY
TO MITIGATE IMPACT THE
DEMOCRATS THE DELAYS ON THE
COMMERCIAL BUDGET CRAB FISHERY.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT IMPROVED
DATA COLLECTION IS CRITICAL TO
RESPOND CHANGING OCEAN FISHERY
CONDITIONS SB EIGHTY SAMPLING
REQUIREMENT FROM YOUR
REQUIREMENT NOT BOTH OREGON AND
WASHINGTON PROVING CERTAINTY
AND STOP ATTACHMENT. AND
SUPPORT MORE DOCTOR MANAGEMENT
DECISIONS ARE CHANGING UP TO
OCEAN CONDITIONS INDUCTIVE
OUTLINED IN SB REMIND WITH TNCS
OWN CONSERVATION GOALS WE
CONTINUE TO APPRECIATE CENTER
MCGUIRE LEADERSHIP ON THESE
ISSUES THAT WE RESPECTFULLY.
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB EIGHTY-
THAT. HEY YOU- WE DO HAVE US DO
WE HAVE ANY ANYONE IN- CHAMBER
THEY WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE. ANYONE IN THE
CONFERENCE ROOM. K. THAT WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES TO SEE
IF- ANYONE IS MODERATOR CALLING
IN TO SUPPORT THE MEASURE. IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME IF YOU'D
ALREADY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THE
QUEUE WAS CLEARED. ONCE AGAIN
FOR SUPPORT SB EIGHTY ONE IN.
ZERO EACH. AND WE DO HAVE ONE
PERSON QUEUING UP IN SUPPORT.
THAT WHEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN TO
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION DIVISION ONLY. NINE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS GREG OUT YOUR- BEEN
A COMMERCIAL FISHING. THE
COMMERCIAL FISHERMEN OUT FOR
TRINIDAD AS FORTY YEARS I AM
ONE OF FOURTEEN MEMBERS OF THE
TRAINER THAT THEY FISHMAN'S
MARKINGS ASSOCIATION- THAT THEY
FISHMAN MARKETING ASSOCIATION
SUPPORTS SB EIGHTY. OKAY THEN I
WILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. THERE
ARE NO OTHER LINES IN SUPPORT.
FOR THANK YOU ARE SO I DO HAVE
A REGISTERED TO A- PERSON
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION OF YOUR
TELEPHONE I MISS MODERATOR IF
YOU CAN NO. YOU THE MAN. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB. TWO EIGHTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU CAN HEAR ME OR NOT
AND MY AUNT WE CAN HEAR YOU.
THANK YOU THE THANK YOU ARE
CHAIRMAN GARCIA OF LECTURE
DALIAN MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
SHERRY HAVING SENT- OF THE
FISHING VESSEL POLITICS- BEEN
NOT PARTICIPATING IN THE
DENTURES CRAWFISH THREE SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE- ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE DENTURE DESCRIBE
PAST FORCE- AND HAVE BEEN ON
THE CROSS FOR SINNERS ACTUALLY
PRIOR TO ITS- ABOUT. THE
INCEPTION- WAS PART OF THE
STEERING COMMITTEE THAT
CREATED- THAT THEIR TASK FORCE
I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE WAY-
WORKING GROUP. AND ALONG WITH
THAT I AM A SUPERVISOR- BILL.
MARK COUNTY AND DISTRICT FOR.
WHILE I AGREE WITH- ALL OF
THOSE THAT ARE IN FAVOR OF- SB
EIGHTY AYE I'M ALSO EXCEPT FOR
THE FAIR START PROVISION- THAT
IS INCLUDED IN THIS BILL- THIS-
GALLAGHER SAID INTEL WAS
AMENDED- I WAS A 100% BEHIND
IT- I'M A GREAT SUPPORTER OF
SANTA BARBARA THANK YOU DOES AN
AWESOME JOB- ALTHOUGH ARE
TALKING TO THE STAFF TOM
MARSHALL I COULD NOT CONVINCE
HIM TO PULL OUT PART OUT. OF
THE BILL- BECAUSE THE DUNGEON
THIS CRAP- TASK FORCE WAS IN
SUPPORT OF IT- AND I'D LIKE TO
SPEAK TO THE MAKE UP OF THAT- A
PAST. NOW IT'S- LAW. AND NOT
PROCESS- I PRESENTE- AND THE-
REPRESENTATION OF THE MOBILE
FLEET- THAT ACTUALLY DOES MOST
OF THE HARVESTING OF THE
PENSIONERS CRAB- IN CALIFORNIA-
IS- LOCALLY. UNDERREPRESENTED
THE FIRST PART- ADDITION THAT
DENNIS STARTED OF A YEARS AGO
WAS THROUGH THE TRI AGENCY
WHICH WAS WASHINGTON OREGON AND
CALIFORNIA- WHICH WAS A FAIR
STARK OF THE ACTION THAT
ACTUALLY DID NOT INCLUDE
DISTRICT TEN BECAUSETHEY WERE
NOT THEY ARE NOT A MEMBER OF
THE VIET TRI STATE-
ORGANIZATION- AND WHAT'S ALL OF
THE- MOVING PARTS THAT ARE
GOING ON NOW WITH THE- CARE
START THAT WE HAVE NOW DOING
TO- DUE TO A SOFT SHELL ISSUE.
AND NOW WE HAVE- THE MORE GAS
AND THEN YOU PUT THIS ON TOP OF
IT- IT'S GOING TO REALLY HAND
COPPER LIMIT THE- OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE MOBILE SUITE TO HARVEST
A PROUD AND GET INTO THE
PROCESSORS- THERE COULD BE-
WITH THAT WITH THIS. A WAILING
TANGLE MEANT ISSUE AND WAS THE
RAMP REGULATIONS- THERE COULD
BE A LACK OF OPPORTUNITY- TO BE
ABLE TO HARVEST THE CROWD THAT
PROCESSORS NEED. TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE THEIR BUSINESS AS WELL
AS- COMMERCIAL. FISHING- WELL-
HE HE- YEAH THAT THIS THIS PART
OF THAT BILL FIRST ART IF YOU
NOT SOMETHING EVERYTHING I
THINK IT'S A BIT PREMATURE- I
IT NEEDS BE A VETTED OUT I
THINK THERE THERE NEEDS TO BE A
YEAR- UNDER OUR BELTS- WITHOUT
IT BEFORE WE DECIDE- THAT DAY
WE NEED THIS FAIR STAR
POSITION- PROVISIONS SKEWS ME-
BUT- LIKE I SAY I WILL NEED THE
ADMINISTRATION PORTION OF THIS
BILL. ON A HUNDRED PERCENT. I
AM. REALLY AN AGREEMENT FOR
THAT- THIS IS A GOOD BILL-
EXCEPT FOR THAT THEIR
CIRCULATION I THINK IT'S-
UNFAIR TO- DON'T YOU LAS VENTAS.
ON THE MOVE UP AND DOWN THE
COAST TO US. TO HELP-
HARVESTING AND PRO- THE CRAP
THANK YOU ARE MUCH THANK YOU.
OKAY SO WAS A WITNESS TO HAVE
IN THE- WE HAVE ONE MORE
WITNESS. OPS ARE DRAWN TO DON
GONZALEZ YES. YEAH CAN YOU HEAR
ME OK YES THIS PROCEED. RIGHT
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON- JERRY
GARCIA MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS JOHN GONZALEZ AND
I'M POLICY SPECIALIST FOR
FISHERY THE PACIFIC SEAFOOD
GROUP. PACIFIC SEAFOOD GROUP IS
A VERTICALLY INTEGRATED SEAFOOD
HARVESTING PROCESSING AND
DISTRIBUTION COMPANY WE ARE A
FAMILY OWNED BUSINESS THAT HAS
BEEN AROUND FOR OVER EIGHTY
YEARS AND WE CURRENTLY EMPLOY
OVER FOUR HUNDRED EMPLOYEES AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AT OUR
LOCATIONS IN EUREKA SACRAMENTO
AND LOS ANGELES. I'M ALSO A
BOARD MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
COAST CRAB ASSOCIATION AND I
REPRESENT THEM AS A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA DUNGENESS CRAB
FISHING YOU'RE WORKING GROUP.
BACK ON MARCH FIFTH WE
SUBMITTED A LETTER OF SUPPORT
FOR SENATE BILL EIGHTY MAINLY
BECAUSE OF THE OBLITERATION
COMPONENT OF BILL. THAT WOULD
ALLOW FOR SOME PRODUCTION
OPPORTUNITIES AT A TIME. WHERE
IT WOULD CURRENTLY BE ILLEGAL
TO DO SO. BUT THEN AN AMENDMENT
WAS ADDED ON APRIL SIX THAT
WOULD APPLY FAIR START TO
DELAYS ASSOCIATED WITH THE RISK
ASSESSMENT MITIGATION PROGRAM.
I'M HERE TODAY TO VOICE MY
OPPOSITION TO THIS FIRST PART
PROVISIONS. IT SEEMS
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATION OPTION THAT
ALLOWS FOR MORE PRODUCTION
OPPORTUNITIES ON ONE HAND.
WHILE HAVING A FAIR START
PROVISION THAT SEVERELY LIMITS
PRODUCTION OPPORTUNITIES ON THE
OTHER HAND. THAT RESULTS IN A
NET LOSS FOR THE CRAB HISTORY
THAT IS ALREADY OVER REGULATED.
OUR CALIFORNIA DOESN'T CRAPPIE
FISHERY IS NOW MANAGED BY THE
RISK ASSESSMENT MITIGATION
PROGRAM WHICH HAS ALREADY
RESULTED IN DEVASTATING.
NEGATIVE ECONOMIC IMPACT SPORT
FISHERMEN ARE PROFITING PLANTS
OUR COASTAL COMMUNITIES. THE
LAST THING OUR FISHERY NEEDS IS
FOR MORE REGULATIONS SUCH AS A
FAIR START PROVISION THAT WOULD
NOT ALLOW FISHERMEN TO GO WHERE
THE CROWDS ARE. THE FLAG CRAB
SEASON WAS ONE OF THE WORST WE
HAVE SEEN IN DECADES. THE CRAB
SIMPLY WERE NOT THERE AND IT
WAS IMPERATIVE THAT THE
FISHERMEN. CAN BE NOBLE AND
MOVE AROUND. IT IF THAT THEY'RE
START PROVISION WAS IN PLACE
FLAT FEE AND- IT WOULD HAVE HAD.
MORE DEVASTATING NEGATIVE
ECONOMIC IMPACTS CORPORATE
SHERMAN ARE PROCESSING PLANTS
AND OUR EMPLOYEES. AND OF
COURSE OUR TO BOOK OUR COASTAL
COMMUNITIES. SIMPLY PUT
FISHERMEN NEED TO BE ABLE TO GO
WHERE THE CROWDS ARE. GOING
CLOTHING WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU VOTE NO ON SB EIGHTY
UNTIL THE FAIR STARTLING WHICH
IS REMOVED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'LL- NOW ASK TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS THAT WANTS TO SPEAK
UP. IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE. I SEE NO ONE ANYONE IN
THE TELECONFERENCE ROOM. I SEE
NO ONE THERE. ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES THIS MODERATOR TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE. TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. BLIND
FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SORRY THIS IS TIFFANY MOCK-
ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHTY ON BEHALF OF OCEANIA
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND SORRY FOR
THE CONFUSION THANK YOU. AND
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHTY THANK
YOU ARE PRETTY WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND SECOND. IT WAS A
MADE BY MR BIGELOW AND THIS
RUBIO- THE DRY CLOTHES ARE ANY
QUESTIONS OR- COMMENTS FROM
ANYONE ON THE- COMMITTEE. SEVEN
NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TWELVE
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND VICE CHAIR I'LL DO
THIS IN THIRTY SECONDS LONG
STORY SHORT I THINK THE WORLD
THE SUPERVISOR HIM ISN'T HE
DOES INCREDIBLE WORK AND WE
HAVE DONE OUR COUNTY THE ONLY
REASON WHY WE HAVE THESE RAM
BREAKS IN THIS BILL. IS BECAUSE
THE TASK FORCE RECOMMENDED ON A
SEVENTEEN TO THREE VOTE THIS IS
AN OMNIBUS BILL I AM A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
DON'T THINK YOU CAN CALL THE-
QUESTION HERE. AT SECTOR. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO HEALTH
COMMITTEE. EDUARDO GARCIA BY
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE DOLLY AYE
DOLLY AYE BENNETT BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I KALRA. KALRA I. LEVINE LEVINE
AYE MURATSUCHI MERE CG I KNOW
WHEN I RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS AYE AYES SMITH SMITH FIVE
IF WE DO IT VIA VIDEO AYE WARD.
ALL RIGHT WILL DO THE FOLLOW UP
IN A ROLL CALL FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO SIGN UP. WILL MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT ITEM. MISTER
JONES SB FOUR SEVENTY HAVE A TO
PASS RECOMMENDATION YOU'LL DO
HAVE TWO WITNESSES THAT WILL
BE- ONE CALLING IN ONE IN
PERSON- PLEASE- PUSHING
INFORMATION ON THE FLOOR READY
FOR YOUR- L. WE HAVE A SECOND
BY MR BIGELOW PLEASE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR PROCEDURE- ALLOW
ME TO PRESENT SENATE BILL FOR
SEVENTY TODAY WHICH CREATES A
COMBINATION HUNTING AND FISHING
LICENSE WHICH WOULD BE VALID
FOR THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
DAYS FROM THE DATE OF PURCHASE.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA ONLY
ALLOWS UNTING AND FISHING
LICENSES TO BE PURCHASED
SEPARATELY HOWEVER MANY OTHER
STATES INCLUDING OUR
NEIGHBORING STATES OF OREGON
ARIZONA NEVADA OFFER ANNUAL
COMBINATION LICENSES. THESE
LICENSES HAVE PROVEN POPULAR BY
MANY SPORTS MEN AND WOMEN
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- THAT BOTH
HUNT AND FISH IN THE SAME YEAR.
SENATE BILL FOR SEVENTY WILL
BRING THIS COMBINATION
LICENSING OPTION TO THE
SPORTSMAN IN CALIFORNIA BY
ENCOURAGING MORE PEOPLE TO BOTH
HUNT AND FISH THE COMBINATION
LICENSE OR SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE'S RECRUITMENT
RETENTION AND REACTIVATION
EFFORTS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
SUPPORT TODAY AND I DO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES- TO SPEAK IN FAVOR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU. WE NEED TO BE A PROFESSOR
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU HAVE A
WITNESS ON THE PHONE MARK
HENLEY FROM CLIFORNIA WATER
FELL HE'S THE LEAD AUGUST
SECOND. ALL RIGHT SIR. THIS
MODERATOR. LOOKING FOR MISTER
HENLEY'S LINE UNLESS HE DIALED
IN AS A PARTICIPANT. MISTER
HENLEY IS NOT CONNECTED. RIGHT
WE CAN GO WITHOUT PUNISHMENT.
OKAY MARC SMITH ON BEHALF OF
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA GUIDES
AND SPORTSMEN AND ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA WATER FELL ON BEHALF
OF MISTER HENLEY WHOSE- NOT
FOUND AT THIS MOMENT SPONSORS
OF THIS LEGISLATION THIS DRIVES
OUT OF THE R. THREE PROCESS
THAT THE STATE HAS BEEN WORKING
ON FOR MULTIPLE YEARS IT'S
RECRUIT REACTIVATE AND RETAIN.
IT'S A CONCEPT OF GETTING MORE
CALIFORNIANS INTO THE
ACTIVITIES OF ANGLING AND
HUNTING AND OUTDOOR RECREATION
PURSUITS THIS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THESE LICENSE REVENUES
GENERATE A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF FUNDING FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL WILDLIFE AS A
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE THAT IS
LARGER THAN A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS AT THIS POINT IN TIME
AND IT'S IN PART DUE TO THE
FACT THAT. FOR EXAMPLE WE SELL
A MILLION FEWER FISHING
LICENSES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAN WE DID IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE DESPITE
THE FACT THAT OUR POPULATION
CONTINUES TO INCREASE DESPITE
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE COASTAL
WATERS THREE THOUSAND MILES OF
INLAND RIVERS AND ENDLESS
OPPORTUNITY. I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
THINK ABOUT LICENSES AS
PRODUCTS IN THE STORE WE HAVE
TO BE INNOVATIVE AND UPDATE
THEM FROM TIME TO TIME SO THAT
THE CONSUMERS WHO PURCHASE THEM
ARE INTERESTED IN THEM THIS
GOES ALONG WITH MOVING TOWARDS
ELECTRONIC LICENSING THIS GOES
TOWARDS CREATING OPTIONS FOR
CONSUMERS TO PURCHASE THESE
PRODUCTS PROVIDE REVENUE TO THE
STATE AND PARTICIPATE IN
OUTDOOR PASTIMES. I'LL CLOSE BY
SAYING THAT DURING THE PANDEMIC
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ALONG
WITH OTHER STATES IN THE
COUNTRY SAW AN EXPONENTIAL
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF FOLKS
WHO ARE TAKING THEIR KIDS
FISHING CORRECT GRADING IN THE
OUTDOORS WE'RE TRYING HUNTING
ARCHERY THOSE KINDS OF SPORTS
FOR THE FIRST TIME WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO BUILD ON THAT WE
WANT TO BRING THIS REVENUE BACK
TO THE DEPARTMENT. HELP THEM
MANAGE THEIR LANDS HELP THEM
WORK WITH HUNTER
CONSERVATIONISTS AND THIS
MEASURE IS A STEP IN THAT
DIRECTION WE ENCOURAGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND MARK ANALLY IS ONLINE MARK
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GREAT HELLO MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ITS MARKETING WITH
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL- OUR
CURRENT HUNTING AND FISHING
SYSTEM IS BASICALLY OUTDATED AS
COMPARED WITH OTHER STATES
CALIFORNIA OFFERS RELATIVELY
FEW TYPES OF HUNTING AND
FISHING LICENSES AND ONLY A
HANDFUL OF CHANGES HAVE BEEN
MADE TO OUR LICENSING SYSTEM IN
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS- LICENSE
SALES WHICH TOTALED EIGHTY FOUR
MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY. BUT
DECLINED OVER THAT TIME PERIOD
DESPITE THE RECENT UPTICK IN
REVENUES DURING THE CALVET
ENDEMIC THIS DECLINE NOT ONLY
CONTRIBUTES TO THE STRUCTURAL
REVENUE AND BALLOT. H. BY THE
WITHOUT DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
WILDLIFE BUT IT HAS NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES FOR WILDLIFE
HABITAT. AND NOT OTHER CONTRA
ACTIVITIES ARE FUNDED THROUGH
LICENSE SALES. SB FOUR SEVENTY
WOULD CREATE A NEW COMBINATION
HUNTING AND FISHING LIFE AND-
SIMILAR TO WHAT ABOUT FORTY
OTHER STATES HAVE- AS NOTED-
OUR NEIGHBORING OREGON ABOUT
AND- ARIZONA THOSE STATE I HAVE
THESE TYPES LICENSES. THE BILL
WOULD ALSO ALLOW THE LIGHT TO
BE VALID THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE DAYS FROM THE DATE OF
PURCHASE A CHANGE WHICH A
NUMBER OF OTHER STATES HAVE
ALSO ADOPTED. THIS WOULD
FACILITATE THE ABILITY OF
LICENSE BUYERS TO MOST
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY
UTILIZE THE LICENSE. IN
ADDITION- LICENSE BUYERS WOULD
BE GIVEN THE OPTION OF AUTO
RENEWAL- DURING THAT DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL WILDLIFE- HUNTING
RECRUITMENT RETENTION AND
REACTIVATION OUR PUBLIC INPUT
PROCESS. THE STAKEHOLDER
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT FOCUSED
ON LIFE AND IN SPECIFICALLY
RECOMMENDED THE CREATION OF A
COMBINATION HUNTING AND FISHING
LICENSE. THERE WAS ALSO- AT TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT NATIONAL STUDY
THAT ASK WHY- THEY WILDLIFE
PROFESSIONALS SUGGEST
INTERCEPTS FACTORS THAT MIGHT
HAVE. AFFECTED LICENSE FAILED
IN THEIR STATE. OF THE STATE
THAT FISH AND WILDLIFE AGENCIES
THAT WERE POLLED IN THE SURVEY.
UP FROM TWENTY EIGHT TO THIRTY
SEVEN PERCENT- NAMED LICENSE.
TYPE CHANGES AS A FACTOR
AFFECTING THEIR ULTIMATE
LICENSE SALES INCREASE SO WE
KNOW THAT THAT IF YOU TYPES OF
LICENSES ARE MARKETED
APPROPRIATELY. THEY CAN SUCCEED.
SO BY OFFERING GREATER CHOICE
COMPLEX BILL YOU KNOW WE
BELIEVE THAT BEFORE SEVENTY
WOULD HELP TO INCREASE FUNDING
FISHING LICENSE SALES AND OF
COURSE THE CONSERVATION FUNDING
BENEFITS THAT THEY PROVIDE WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'LL ASK IF
THERE ARE ANY. INDIVIDUALS IN
THE CHAMBERS WANT TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE. ANYONE
IN THE CONFERENCE ROOM. ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE AS MODERATOR
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SEVEN ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. LINE SIXTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU CHAIR
AND MEMBERS JERRY DESMOND ON
BEHALF OF RECREATIONAL BOATERS
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
THAT BEFORE SEVENTY THANK YOU.
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT
PERFECT- WILL ASK- I DON'T HAVE
ANYONE LISTED TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION- I'LL ASK IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN- THE CHAMBERS
SPEAKING OPPOSITION. SEE NO ONE
ANYONE IN THE CONFERENCE ROOM.
YOU KNOW ONE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE AS MODERATOR
SPEAKING OPPOSITION. TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR
SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE IS NO
ONE WISHING TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR SEVENTY
THANK YOU TO HAVE. BY BILL
SACRAMENTO SMITH- AREN'T ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BY THE
MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA BRING IT
BACK TO THE OPERATOR OF THE
BILL. AND LIKE CLOTHES. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN ASARE AYE
VOTE IN RIGHT WILL CALL
QUESTION HERE I HAVE NOT
CHECKED THEIR- NUMBER IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATE. EDUARDO
GARCIA HI EDUARDO GARCIA I DALI
DALI I'D BENNETT BENNETT I
BIGELOW. FIVE BIGELOW FIVE
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN HI CRISTINA
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA I KALRA.
LEVINE LEVINE AYE MURATSUCHI
MERE SU CHI I KNOW WHEN I KNOW
WHEN I RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS
SALAS I SMITH. SMITH FIVE YOU
HAVE TO DO IT VIEW VIDEO AYE
WARD. OKAY WE'LL LEAVE THAT
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD
ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN WE HAVE-
ANOTHER SENATOR HERE BECAUSE SB
FIVE FIVE NINE CENTER TITLED
THIS BILL HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. SHE ALSO HAS
TWO WITNESSES THAT WILL BE
SPEAKING IN PERSON AND SUPPORT
WE ALSO HAVE TO WITNESSES
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION VIA
TELEPHONE AGAIN THIS BILL HAS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION SHE IS
HERE WITH US ALREADY YOU MAY
BEGIN. YOUR PRESENTATION. FOR
THE MOTION WHICH BIGELOW SECOND
BY MRS SALAS AGAIN YOU DO HAVE
A FEW PASSED RECOMMENDATION.
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M HERE 2% SB
FIVE FIVE NINE THE STATE WATER
RESILIENCY ACT. LAST SESSION I
INTRODUCED A BILL OF THE SAME
NUMBER THAT REQUESTED FUNDING
TO RESTORE THE CARRYING
CAPACITY OF THE FRANKLIN CANAL.
THAT BILL WAS ULTIMATELY VETOED
BY THE GOVERNOR BUT STARTED A
LARGER CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
NEED TO REPAIR MUCH NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT CAN BETTER
PREPARE US FOR OUR WATER NEEDS
AND DROUGHT AND NON DROUGHT
YEARS. THIS CONVERSATION WAS
CHAMPION ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL
BUT CENTER FEINSTEIN'S OFFICE
IN CONGRESSMAN COST AS OFFICE.
THEY CONTINUE TO LEAD THIS
CONVERSATION TODAY WHAT THE
FEDERAL ASK THAT MEMBERS ASK
AYE BRING BEFORE YOU TO LAY OUT
A PLAN FOR FULLY FUNDING.
CANNELLA CONVEYANCE REPAIRS ON
THE CALIFORNIA AQUEDUCT THE
DELTA MENDOTA CANAL THE SAN
LUIS CANAL AND THE FRANK KERN
CANAL. I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
TELLING YOU ABOUT A SMALL TOWN
IN MY DISTRICT A COMMUNITY
ACTIVIST AND- TODAY THOMASTON
HAS BEEN WITHOUT WATER FOR
TWENTY ONE DAYS. TO RESIDENT OF
THE TOWN OF SEVEN HUNDRED
PEOPLE THAT RELY ON WATER FROM
THE CANALS TO RECHARGE ITS
GROUND WATER AQUIFERS. IT'S
LOCATED BELOW THE PINCH POINT
OR WERE THE SUBSIDENCE ON THE
FRANKLIN CANAL IS AT ITS WORST.
AND AS A RESULT LOST OUT ON THE
WATER IT COULD HAVE USED FOR
RECHARGE IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS. THE WELL IN THIS TOWN IS
NO LONGER FUNCTIONING AND THEY
ARE HAVING TO TRUCK WATER IN
FROM PORTER BILL. ABOUT TWENTY
MILES AWAY. FOR TWENTY ONE DAYS
PEOPLE IN THIS TOWN HAVE NOT
HAD WATER FURTHER SWAMP COOLERS
TO PROVIDE RELIEF FROM THE
BLISTERING SUMMER HEAT THAT WE
HAVE RECENTLY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND REALLY ACROSS. THE
ENTIRE STATE I HAVE SEEN. FOR
TWENTY ONE DAYS THEY HAVE BEEN
UNABLE TO VAPOR CHILDREN COOK
THE FOOD OR FLUSH THEIR TOILETS
WITH WATER RUNNING FROM THEIR
TAX. MANY COMMUNITIES WILL BE
CELEBRATING THE FOURTH OF JULY
THIS WEEKEND WITH FIREWORKS.
THE RISK OF DOING SO UNTIL
RESIDENT. COULD HAVE
DEVASTATING CONSEQUENCES
BECAUSE FOR TWENTY ONE DAYS
THEY HAVE NOT HAD THE WATER
PRESSURE. TO PUT OUT FIRES.
ANOTHER COMMUNITY IN MY
SENATE-DISTRICT AVENUE HOME TO
THIRTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO
ARE MOSTLY FARMWORKERS.
PREDICTS THEY WILL BE WITHOUT
WATER BY AUGUST. AVENAL
RECEIVES WATER FROM THE ST
LOUIS CANAL PER THE CALIFORNIA
ACCIDENT. PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT
REAL PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING NOW
BECAUSE THESE CANALS ARE IN
DIRE NEED OF REPAIR. INVESTING
IN THESE CANALS WON'T HELP THEM
TODAY BUT TO DO THAT WE WOULD
HAVE TO INVEST. HAVE HAD
INVESTED YEARS AGO INVESTING
TODAY WILL ENSURE THAT WE AND
THEY ARE BETTER PREPARED FOR
THE FUTURE. IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WE LOST AN ESTIMATED THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF
WATER THAT COULD HAVE BEEN PUT
BACK INTO THE GROUND TO
RECHARGE OUR AQUIFERS. THAT
AMOUNT OF WATER COULD HAVE
PROVIDED FOR A CITY OF THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND TO FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND FOR A
WHOLE YEAR. WE MUST INVEST NOW
AS WE ARE BETTER PREPARED FOR
NEXT ROUTE SO WE ARE NOT IN THE
SAME POSITION E ARE TODAY.
WITH TALENTS LIKE THOSE IN MY
DISTRICT THAT ARE WITHOUT WATER.
THE WATER PROVIDED BY THESE
CANALS ISN'T JUST. USED BY
RESIDENTS OF MY DISTRICT. IT IS
ALSO USED BY CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS IN RURAL COMMUNITIES
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY BUT URBAN
USERS AND LOS ANGELES AND THE
GREATER BAY AREA. ASSEMBLY
THIRTY ONE MILLION OF THEM.
SOME OF WHOM LIVE IN OUR
STATE'S MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. THIS WATER ALSO
PROTECTS THE LARGEST REMAINING
WETLAND COMPLEX IN THE WESTERN
UNITED STATES WHICH IS HOME TO
OVER ONE. MILLION MIGRATING
BIRDS AND IS RECOGNIZED AS THE
WETLAND OF INTERNATIONAL
IMPORTANCE. AND YES IT IS USED
BY OUR STATE SMALL AND LARGE
FARMERS THESE FARMERS
CONTRIBUTE ABOUT FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS TO THE STATE'S ECONOMY.
COLLECTIVELY AND PROVIDE
THOUSANDS OF JOBS FOR
FARMWORKERS. BUT THIS ISN'T
JUST A FINANCIAL INVESTMENT IT
IS AN INVESTMENT IN OUR FOOD
SECURITY. CALIFORNIA FARMS NOT
ONLY FEED OUR CONSTITUENTS
BEFORE THE NATION. SB FIVE FIVE
NINE PROVIDES US THE
OPPORTUNITY NOT ONLY TO PLAN
FOR FUTURE BUT TO PROTECTED AS
WELL. THE BILL LAYS OUT A PLAN
TO FULLY FUND THE CANAL
REPAIRS. AT SOME AT SEVEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE COURSE OF TEN
YEARS. FOR PERSONAL PROVIDING
THAT BENEFIT TO THE ENTIRE
STATE. IT IS IMPERATIVE WE
INVEST IN REPAIRING THESE
CANALS TODAY. EMBRACING A LOCAL
AND FEDERAL PARTNERSHIPS TO DO
SO CREATING NEEDED AND GOOD
PAYING JOBS. HELPING US
EFFECTIVELY MEET OUR
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER GOALS
AND ENSURING OUR CAPACITY TO
REMAIN THE FOOD CAPITAL OF THE
WORLD. AND SECURING ACCESS TO
CLEAN DRINKING WATER FOR
AFFORDABLE COMMUNITIES. AND TO
JUSTIFY SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
HAVE JENNIFER PIERRE WITH THE
STATE WATER CONTRACTORS. AND
RICHARD ORTEGA FROM WESTLANDS
WATER DISTRICT. I THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN FOR
THE COMMITTEE THE FULL THING MY
NAME IS JENNIFER PAYER AND ON
THE GENERAL MANAGER OF THE
STATE WATER CONTRACTORS WE
REPRESENT PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA THE CONTRACT
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES FOR STATE WATER
PROJECT WATER THE FEDERAL AND
STATE OWNED CANALS IDENTIFIED
IN SB FIVE FIVE NINE ARE
CRITICAL TO SUPPORT CLIMATE
CHANGE RESILIENCE BY
FACILITATING THE MOVEMENT OF
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF WATER
WHEN IT'S WET. TO STORAGE FOR
USE DURING DROUGHT THESE CANALS
PROVIDE DRINKING WATER TO
THIRTY ONE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS
IRRIGATION WATER TO OVER THREE
MILLION ACRES OF FARMLAND. BUT
THE SILENCE WHICH HAS BEEN
OCCURRING IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY FOR NEARLY A CENTURY HAS
DRASTICALLY REDUCED SUPPLY
RELIABILITY. AND INCREASED
ENERGY CONSUMPTION. FOR EXAMPLE
THE STATE WATER PROJECT IS
ALREADY EXPERIENCING A 33%
REDUCTION OF DESIGN FLOW
CAPACITY. AND AN ADDITIONAL
FIFTEEN TO THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR AND HIGHER
OPERATIONAL AND POWER COSTS.
THIS IS THE ANIMAL GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT OF TWENTY
FOURTEEN. WILL ENSURE
SUBSIDENCE DOESN'T CONTINUE.
WHILE SB FIVE FIVE NINE WILL
FUND REPAIRS TO THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT SUPPORT THE
STATE'S ECONOMY CLIMATE
RESILIENCY FOOD SECURITY
ECOSYSTEM HEALTH. AND
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION GOALS.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THE
GOVERNOR'S TWENTY TWENTY VETO
MESSAGE BY ESTABLISHING A
HOLISTIC STATEWIDE SOLUTION. TO
RESTORE THE CAPACITY OF THE
FOUR MAJOR CANALS THAT SERVE
SEVENTY EIGHT PERCENT. OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION.
INCLUDING AN EQUAL THREE WAY
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL COST
SHARE. THE PRODUCTS WERE BUILT
TO PROVIDE MULTIPLE BENEFITS TO
THE PUBLIC INCLUDING FLOOD
CONTROL ENVIRONMENTAL FLOWS AND
HYDRO ELECTRICITY. ON TOP OF
DIRECT BENEFITS OF WATER
SUPPLY. THESE BENEFITS SPREAD
ACROSS THE STATE THROUGH JOB
CREATION TAX REVENUES AND OTHER
BENEFITS. THROUGH THE COST
SHARING ARRANGEMENT
CONTEMPLATED IN FIVE FIVE NINE
THE STATE WATER PROJECT AND
CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT. CAN
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THESE
BENEFITS THROUGHOUT THE STATE-
GATHER WITH FEDERAL FUNDING
FROM TWO COMPANION BILLS
INTRODUCED BY US SENATOR DIANNE
FEINSTEIN. AND CONGRESSMAN JIM
ACOSTA. AND A LOCAL COST SHARE
WE HAVE A ONCE IN A LIFETIME
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE CURRENT STATE BUDGET
SURPLUS TO LEVERAGE LOCAL AND
FEDERAL DOLLARS. FOR IMPORTANT
INFRASTRUCTURE SYSTEMS IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL SPONSORED
BY THE FRONT WATER AUTHORITY
SAN LUIS AND DELTA MENDOTA
WATER AUTHORITY AND THE STATE
WATER CONTRACTORS. I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE FIVE NINE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS RICARDO
ORTEGA GENERAL MANAGER OF THE
GRASS AND WATER DISTRICT AND
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCY. I ALSO SERVED AS A
BOARD MEMBER ON THE SAN LUIS
AND DELTA MENDOTA WATER
AUTHORITY. COMPRISED OF TWENTY
SEVEN AGRICULTURAL MUNICIPAL
AND ENVIRONMENTAL WATER
AGENCIES. THAT OPERATE MAINTAIN
THE DELTA MENDOTA CANAL. I'M
PLEASED TO TESTIFY TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIVE NINE.
THE FEDERAL DELTA MENDOTA IN
FRONT KERN CANALS HAVE LOST
SIGNIFICANT FLOW CAPACITY OVER
THE DECADES TO LAND SUBSIDENCE.
WHICH IS IMPACTED THE ABILITY
TO RELIABLY DELIVER WATER TO
MANY SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
COMMUNITIES FARMS AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. THESE CANALS
CONVEY WATER TO MILLIONS OF
ACRES OF FARMLAND. AND TO THE
LAST REMAINING 5% OF WETLANDS
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
THESE WEAPONS RECHARGE AQUIFERS
AND ROUTE SUPPORT MILLIONS OF
MIGRATORY BIRDS AND OTHER
WILDLIFE EACH YEAR. THE GRASS
AND WATER DISTRICT CONVEYS
WATER TO WILDLIFE REFUGES THAT
ARE RECOGNIZED AS WELL THE MOST
IMPORTANT WETLAND ECOSYSTEMS
REMAINING IN IN THE AMERICANS.
WETLANDS AND WILDLIFE REQUIRE
ADEQUATE SUPPLY THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR ON A SCHEDULE THAT IS MOST
BENEFICIAL TO THEM. SUBSIDENCE
ALONG THESE CANALS THREATENS
THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE ENOUGH
WATER TO THE HABITAT AND TO THE
AND TO KEEP WILDLIFE
POPULATIONS HEALTHY. RESTORING
THE CAPACITY AND IS THE FIRST
CRITICAL STEP IN BUILDING
RESILIENCY IN A CHANGING
CLIMATE. DROUGHTS ARE NOW MORE
SIGNIFICANT MORE FREQUENT
LONGER LASTING AND MORE SEVERE
STORMS ARE WARMER PRODUCE LESS
NOW BUT ALSO MORE FLOODING.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS WATER
FACILITIES THAT CAN RECAPTURE
FLOOD WATER EFFICIENTLY. AND
DELIVER IT TO LAND SECOND
RECHARGE THE AQUIFER.
CALIFORNIA'S WATER SYSTEM IS
INTERCONNECTED AND WAS BUILT ON
A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN LOCALS
THE STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENTS. SB FIVE FIVE NINE
ON THAT PARTNERSHIP BY
PROVIDING. A STATE MATCH TO
LOCAL COMMITMENTS TO RESTORE
THE BACKBONE INFRASTRUCTURE THE
CALIFORNIANS ON THE ENVIRONMENT
DEPEND ON. WHAT CREATING AND
SUSTAINING THOUSANDS OF JOBS IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. CRITICS
ARE SAYING THIS FUNDING SHOULD
BE RAN THROUGH A MORE
CUMBERSOME STATE AGENCY.
FUNDING PROCESS BUT TO WHAT END
WE DO NOT NEED TO SLOW THIS
DOWN. THIS IS AN THIS IS AN
EMERGENCY. WE ARE AGAINST THE
STATE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
IMPLEMENTING. AND IMPLEMENTING
THESE PROJECTS SO LONG AS IT
DOES NOT SLOW DOWN OR KILL
THESE EFFORTS. THANK YOU. THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASK TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE AND- ON THE
FLOOR TO SUPPORT THE MEASURE.
AND THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN RESERVE THE
COMMITTEE KATHY BE A
TELEKINETIC POWERS IN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT ALL RIGHT
ANYONE ELSE HERE. TO SUPPORT.
YEAH ANYONE IN THE- THE A
CONFERENCE ROOM IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES I'M
AS MODERATOR IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. YES SEVERAL IN SUPPORT OF.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO TO
GET INTO THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT
OF S. B. FIVE FIVE NINE. I'M
NOT ALREADY DONE SO WHEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ONLY LINE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MONICA MILLER REPRESENT
ANYTHING I WANTED TO CHECK
MORNING TAX WHERE THIRTY
COMPOUND THAT DOCUMENT DON'T
ACCOUNT FOR PART OF THEIR
DRINKING WATER NEEDS THANK YOU
THAT THE FUNDING IS ONLY
PRACTICAL TERMS NOT TREATED
TENS OF MILLIONS. ON THE
INSTRUCTOR PILOT BY EIGHT BY SB
FIVE FIVE NINE AND THE URGENT.
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT NEXT
FIRST. LINE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ATTACKING AND WE WOULD
SHOW YOUR EMPLOYEES MILDREN
LAYING HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF TO COUNTIES- TULARE
COUNTY AND KERN COUNTY OVER
THIRTY ONE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
DEPEND ON THE WATER THAT FLOWS
THROUGH THE STATE WATER
PROJECT. AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY
NOW PROJECT I'M GONNA RUN
THROUGH HOMES FARMS AND
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND VERY CRUCIAL
INVESTMENTS TO BRING THESE
CRUCIAL CRITICAL- PARTS OF THE
STATE'S- WATER DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEM A GOOD STATE OF REPAIR
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE THANK
SENATOR MCCONNELL. WHO BRING
THE BILLBOARD AND WE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU EXPRESSEN. LINE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TRICIA CHARACTER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THE FIVE FIVE NINE. R. FOR.
THANKS. LINE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE NEARBY BUT HIGHER
THAN WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. LINE SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN VIRTUALLY ALL THE
DISSERTATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
LINE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL CHAIR MEMBERS
BECAUSE EL DORADO ON BEHALF OF
THE ANTELOPE VALLEY EAST WATER
CREATES THE EXPORT. LINE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBER ANTHONY MILLION
ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA CLARITAVALLEY WATER AGENCIES AND THE
SAN GIVE A VALID MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN THERE'S SOME GEISEL A
BROKEN GROUP ON BEHALF OF OUR
CLIENTS KERN COUNTY WATER
AGENCY STANDARD AND YOU KNOW
VALUES FOR WATER DISTRICT AGER
WIRED CONSERVER CONSERVATION
DISTRICT AND KINGS RIVER WATER
SENSATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
REBEKAH BACK AND ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL
CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA COTTON
JENNER'S AND GROWERS
ASSOCIATION TULARE LAKE BASIN
WATER STORAGE DISTRICT AND
WESTERN AGRICULTURAL PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION AND THE COURT THANK
YOU SENATOR HER TADO FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. LINE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CARE MEMBERS THIS IS
CHRIS CON REPRESENTED THE
COACHELLA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. BLIND
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
DANNY MERKLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS IF MY
CLIENT ON BEHALF OF CLIENT
WATER AUTHORITY IN STRONG
SUPPORT WE TAKE THE SENATOR THE
BIPARTISAN AND BICAMERAL
COALITION THANK YOU. NINE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS THIS IS
GAIL CALLAHAN WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON- THE
KALAYAAN I WOULD SLEEP OVER
METHYLATION ON BEHALF OF VALLEY
ON WATER QUALITY XIN INVESTOR
WATER AGENCY IN SUPPORT. AND
LINE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CAROLYN
JENSEN ON BEHALF THE MAFIA
WATER AGENCIES IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THERE ARE NO THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE FOR
SUPPORT ON THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE DO HAVE TWO FOLKS
THERE WILL BE- TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION- THE TELEPHONE WE
PLEASE- ELEVEN. BRANDEN DAWSON
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
SIR MEMBERS BRENNAN DAWSON
DIRECTORS HERE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC A THIRD YEAR IN A ROW WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SENATE BILL
FIVE FIVE NINE. TWO MAJOR
ISSUES WITH THIS BILL FIRST BY
INCLUDING TWO FEDERALLY ON
CANAL SYSTEMS OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY PROJECT WE REALLY DIDN'T
HAVE MUCH KNOWLEDGE OF THE
BENEFICIARY PAYS PRINCIPLE
WHICH REQUIRES THOSE WHO
BENEFIT FROM THE PROJECT
PAPERCLIP BENEFIT. FROM SUBJECT
AT THE COMMITTEE KNOWLEDGE THIS
ACCURATELY STATES PARK
TECHNOLOGY PART OF THE C. B. P.
AND OPERATED FOR BENEFIT OF
MOSTLY AGRICULTURE- GATORS IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
SIMILARLY WITH THE DOCUMENT ON
ACCOUNT AND ARGUED THOSE
BENEFICIARIES MAINLY LARGE
AFTER AGRICULTURAL ENTITIES%
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE SPONSORS
AND THE PROPONENTS REQUIRED. IN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD
BEAR THE COST TO REPAIR NOT
STATE TAXPAYERS WE KNOW THE
COMMUNITY TO RECEIVE WATER FROM
THESE ISSUES THE ONLY HAPPY TO
WORK WITH THE OFFENSE ANSWERS
TO FIND A SOLUTION THAT ENABLES
BOTH THE TO CONTINUE RECEIVING
THAT WATER BUT AS WRITTEN AT
THREE FIVE FIVE NINE WOULD YOU
SIGN TO STOP STATE TAXPAYERS.
INCLUDING THOSE IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE STATE TO ESSENTIALLY
SUBSIDIZE AGRICULTURAL CROP
PRODUCTION GLOBAL GLOBAL
TOWARDS THE REPAIR MISSION
HEALTHY CELLS OR JUST THE
UNDERLYING PROBLEM. WHICH WHICH
BY SEVEN POINT. I BACKUP NOT
DID NOT NO DRUG THE VERY OF THE
BILL SEEKS TO A- LAND BLANTON.
CALLED BY ALL POPULAR I LOT OF
RESEARCH. IMPLEMENT OF SIX AND-
IN THE GROUNDWATER BUT ARTS
GEORGE RESULTS JUMPED. FORTY
EVEN MANY OF THE GROUNDWATER.
PLAN THAT BEEN COMMITTED THE
STATE SUFFICIENT WHICH TAKES
NOT MAKE SUCH AS SOON OF
INVESTMENT WITH A COMPLETE. AS
TO THE- LINES WILL HAVE ON YOUR
SYSTEM. OVER THAT TWENTY YEARS.
WE'D BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH ON
THESE MEASURES AS WELL AS WITH
THE AUTHORS. THERE DID ABOUT NO
AS WE GOT OF NINE THANK YOU.
HERE KNOW LIKE LINE SEAT.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTER MY NAME
IS MICHAEL INTHE OF THE POLICY
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR THE
OPTION TO A COMMENT. ON ONE OF
POST SB FIVE FIVE NINE IT IS
AMENDED IT COMMITS THE TO SEVEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE MILLION AND
SPENDING UPON APPROPRIATION
WITHOUT OVERSIGHT OR
TRANSPARENCY REGARDING THE
PUBLIC BENEFITS ARISING FROM
THE STATE INVESTMENT THE EXTENT
OF THE PRIVATE BENEFICIARY
KASHA OR THE DURABILITY OF THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT HAS
GROUNDWATER OVERDRAFT CONTINUES
WELL STATEMENT IS BEING RAMPED
UP OVER THE NEXT TWO DECADES.
HOW DID ONE KNOWS THE RELIABLE
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE IS
ESSENTIAL FOR PEOPLE THE
ENVIRONMENT AND AGRICULTURE AND
THAT THERE ARE ALL IMPORTANT WE
SUPPORT THESE A PUBLIC FUNDS TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE REPAIR THESE
CONVEYANCES AND WE KNOW THAT
THESE THAT WE NEED TO A PARIS
CONVENTUS QUICKLY AND
EFFICIENTLY AND I AND I AGREE
WITH HER COULD TAKE ON THAT
PART WE DON'T WANT TO GET
BOGGED DOWN RIGHT NOW. HOWEVER
SB FIVE FIVE NINE SHOULD BE
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVED TO
ENSURE OVERSIGHT TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THE
INSURANCE THE PUBLIC BENEFITS
NOTABLY THE COMPANION FEDERAL
LEGISLATION IS AT LEAST
SOMEWHAT MORE DETAILED ON THESE
ISSUES INCLUDING OVERSIGHT
BECAUSE SHARE PROJECT DESIGN
ENVIRONMENTAL COMPLIANCE FOR SB.
FIVE FIV NINE PLAN WHICH IS
PRETTY THREADBARE. THE
COMMITTEE AND I OF AS FIVE FIVE
NINE PLAY NO RECALL FOR THE- OF
PUBLIC BENEFITS FOR HIGH. OF
MILLIONS OF STATE TAX DOLLARS
ALLOWANCE BENEFITS PUBLIC
SEGMENTS FOR THE DIFFERENT
SEGMENTS THAT WOULD BE
REPAIRED. NO THOSE BENEFITS
PROVIDED FOR EXAMPLE BY THE DMC
ARE DIFFERENT AND BENEFITS
PROVIDED ELSEWHERE THERE'S NO
WAY TO DETERMINE THAT IN THE
BILL OR IN THIS PROCESS. IT'S A%
MASSIVE DEPARTURE THE PRESIDENT
SET BY PROP ONE. AND A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPROVE ON THE
MULTIPLE BENEFITS PROVIDED BY
THE WATER INFRASTRUCTURE.
ESPECIALLY AS WE MODERNIZE MY
PARENTS. IT ONLY ALLUDES TO
ADEQUATE COST SHARE BEHIND NO
TRANSPARENCY OR ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR THE KASHA BY THE DIRECT
PRIVATE BENEFICIARIES THE STATE
INVESTMENT. FOR THE PRIVATE
ENTITIES THAT CAUSED THE DAMAGE
THAT MUST NOW BE REPAIRED.
FINALLY SB FIVE FIVE NINE HAS
NO LANGUAGE TO PROTECT THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT CHRONIC
OVERDRAFT CONTINUES WALKED
EGGMAN IS BEING IMPLEMENTED. IN
FUTURE DAMAGE TO THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL LIKELY NEED
FURTHER TAXPAYER INVESTMENTS.
SENATOR HER TITLE RIGHTLY
RAISES THE ISSUES OF COMMUNITY
SUFFERING DUE TO THE LOSS OF
WELLS. WHICH HAVE BEEN THE
RESULT OF OVER PUMPING OF
GROUNDWATER PRIMARILY FOR
AGRICULTURAL PURPOSES HAS HE
FIVE FIVE NINE DOES NOT ADDRESS
THAT PROBLEM CONTINUED- GRAFT
IN THE NEAR TERM. IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE ASSURANCES THE PUBLIC
BENEFITS SUCH AS DRINKING WATER
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMITTEES OR
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT WILL BE
PRIORITIZED. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
OUTOF ON TRY TO. SUPPORT
SENATOR- HER DAUGHTER'S FIVE
FIVE NINE WITH PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS WHICH WERE DISMISSED
WITHOUT DISCUSSION. WE DO WANT
YOU CAN DANCE IS TO BE
EXPEDITIOUSLY REPAIR. BUT AS
THE WATER COMMISSION HAS
RECOMMENDED TAXPAYER INVESTMENT
SHOULD COME UP WITH SOME
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
TRANSPARENCY AND RESILIENCY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE IN
THE- AUDIENCE- WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. BUT THIS BILL SEE
NO ONE ANYONE IN THE CONFERENCE
ROOM. ANYONE THE PHONE LINE
WHICH IS BIG IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. CHAU MODERATOR
COMMENTED OPPOSITE. THE COMPANY
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION. THERE'S
NO ONE QUEUING UP THANK YOU WE
WILL UP BRING THE MEASURE BACK
TO THE CHAMBERS I'VE GOT A
COUPLE MICROPHONES THAT ARE UP
FIRST ONE IS THAT SOME MEMBERS
SALAS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE SB FIVE FIVE NINE
LIKE SENATOR TODD WHO STATED
THIS IS VERY CRITICAL NOT ONLY
JUST OF THE VALLEY BUT REALLY
FIXNG CALIFORNIA'S. PIPE WORKS
IN THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THIS IS A PROBLEM
THAT'S BEEN NEGLECTED FOR
DECADES ON END. YOU KNOW
THROUGH NO FAULT OF. OF ANYONE
HERE ASIDE FROM NOT TAKING
ACTION YOU KNOW THE SUBSIDENCE
ISSUES OF THE THING HAPPENING
NATURALLY THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE NEED TO FIX
THOSE PIPE WORKS THIS BILL SB
FIVE FIVE NINE. GOES A LONG WAY
I CAN TELL YOU THERE'S A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE SUFFERING
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT ABLE TO MOVE
WATER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE HAD UP HERE.
LESS THAN A WEEK AGO I BELIEVE
IT WAS YOU KNOW.
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
TOUGHEST WATER DISTRICT YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW IF
A FIRE WERE TO OCCUR THEY DON'T
EVEN HAVE THE WATER PRESSURE TO
PUT OUT A FIRE. RIGHT THEY
DON'T HAVE WE HEAR UP AND DOWN
THE ENTIRE VALLEY AND
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE
WHERE PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING
STILL TRYING TO GET SAFE
DRINKING WATER. RIGHT THAT'S AN
ISSUE THAT CONTINUES TO BE
PROMINENT IT'S AN ISSUE THAT
CONTINUES TO BE PERVASIVE IT'S
AN ISSUE THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS. AND ULTIMATELY I DO I
DO WANNA. BUT I WANT TO GO TO A
SITE BUT I DO WANT TO CONCLUDE
WITH THIS I DO WANT TO THANK
THE MEMBERS. IN THIS CHAMBER
THAT DID VOTE FOR THE BUDGET
BILL THAT ALLOCATED A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TOWARDS WATER
CONVEYANCE WHICH IS THE EXACT
MEASURES. AS SPECIFIED IN SB
FIVE FIVE NINE. AND WHAT THAT
ARE STRICTLY ASK EVERYONE TO
VOTE I. THANK YOU WE'LL ASK A-
SUMMER SPENT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. I RISE IN BIG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL I ROSE UP ON THIS
FLOOR MONDAY MARCH. MONDAY
SESSION. AS FOR A BUDGET
AMENDMENT FOR A BILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S A BI FOLKS. WE NEED TO
START DOING INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THE STATE FOR WATER. TO GET IT
TO THE CITIZENS. YOU HEARD THE
STORY OF TWENTY ONE DAYS MOST
OF US ARE PRETTY COMPLACENT. WE
GO THE FAUCET WE TURN IT ON
WATER COMES ON. A MAGIC IF YOU
TURNED ON YOUR FAUCET AND
NOTHING CAME OUT. THAT AFFECTS
EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA WE NEED
TO START MAKING THE INVESTMENT
FOR WATER STORAGE. WATER
RELIABILITY AND CLEAN DRINKING
WATER IN THE STATE. HOPE MY
COLLEAGUES I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN THE FUTURE
FOR MORE WATER INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA LOOK FORWARD TO AN
AYE VOTE SHOULD BE UNANIMOUS.
THANK YOU LESTER. OKAY THE
PROMISE OF RESENTMENT SKINNER
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND FOR THE BILL BY ME WHO
MADE THAT. SALAS AND MISTER
BIGELOW- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS IF I MAY- IN MY CLOSING
I'D LIKE TO SHOW A PICTURE- IF
PLEASE PLEASE THANK YOU. FOR
TWENTY ONE DAYS THE COMMUNITY
ACTIVIST AND- HAS NO WATER THIS
IS A PICTURE OF EIGHT. THE
PERSON THAT LIVES IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT HAD IT HAS THE
BATHTUB FILLED WITH WATER. AND
HE GETS WATER FROM THIS BATHTUB
THAT IN HIS HOME TO BE ABLE TO
FLUSH HIS TOILET. SO I
UNDERSTAND THE ARGUMENTS THAT
ARE MADE TODAY. BY THE
OPPOSITION BUT THERE'S URGENCY
COLLEAGUES THERE'S URGENCY AND
FUNDING FOR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR WATER
SECURITY THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS
ISSUE WE ARE IN A DROUGHT. AND
IF THIS CONTINUES IF THIS
DROUGHT CONTINUES UNTIL NEXT
YEAR. WHAT CALIFORNIANS ARE
GOING TO BE INA WORSE
SITUATION. THIS IS THE
COMMUNITY OF THOMASTON TODAY.
BUT TOMORROW AND OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE OF MONTHS IT'S GOING TO
BE MORE COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE. YOU CAN MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN THAT THAT'S
JUST A REALITY IN IF WE DON'T
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT NOW TODAY
BECAUSE WE- WERE LONG OVERDUE.
WE'RE GOING TO BE IN SOME
SERIOUS SERIOUS PROBLEM WE
ALREADY ARE SO. WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO- OFF FOR AN ELBOW THANK
YOU THE TO PASS INFORMATION IS
A GOOD APPROPRIATIONS LOSSES
SECRETARY CALL. THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA
HI EDUARDO GARCIA AYE DOLLY AYE
DOLLY AYE BENNETT. BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE FRIEDMAN CRISTINA
GARCIA. CRISTINA GARCIA I
KALRA. LEVIN LEVINE I NEVER SU
CHI. WHEN. NO WHEN I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS SO AS I SMITH
IF I COULD DO IT THE VIDEO HI
WARD WARD I THANK YOU WE ARE
DOWN TO THE LAST TWO THREE
BILLS MEMBERS WE HAVE ONE
AUTHOR HERE MISTER DODD SENATOR
DODD- SB SIX TWO SIX THREE OF A
SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION YOU DO
HAVE TO. WITNESSES ONE PERSON
ONE TELEPHONE PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS SB SIX
TWENTY SIX WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
D. W. R. TO USE DESIGN BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER GENERAL
CONTRACTOR PROCUREMENT METHODS
FOR PROJECT DELIVERY FOR
FACILITIES OF THE STATE WATER
PROJECT EXCLUDING. THE DELTA
CONVEYANCE D. W. OURS STATE
WATER PROJECT S. W. P. DRIVE
OVER FOUR HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IN
ITALY PROVIDING WATER TO TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION CALIFORNIANS IN
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRES OF FARMLAND. THE
S. W. P. DDITIONALLY DELIVERS
EXTENSIVE HYDROELECTRIC POWER
AND FLOOD PROTECTION MUCH OF
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
SUPPORTS THE S. W. P. IS OVER
SIXTY YEARS OLD IN ISSUES OF
SUBSIDENCE A CLIMATE CHANGE OF
INCREASE THE CHALLENGES. ALL
DEMANDS OF MAINTENANCE FOR THIS
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE THE
AUTHORITY TO UTILIZE THESE
PROCUREMENT METHODS WILL
PROVIDE D. W. R. WITH GREATER
FLEXIBILITY AND EXPERTISE WHEN
CONSTRUCTING CRITICAL WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ACCELERATE
PROJECT COMPLETION. TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS
JENNIFER PIERRE ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS AND
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IS JEANNIE
COULD TELL ON BEHALF OF THE W.
R. THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE
RECEIVE. FOUR ZERO I THINK THE.
GOOD MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON
AGAIN- AS YOU KNOW MY NAME
JENNIFER PIERRE REPRESENTING
THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS AYE
WE DELIVER WATER TO TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION CALIFORNIANS AND
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
ACRES OF FARMLAND THE STATE
WATER PROJECT IS A COLLECTION
OF SEVEN HUNDRED MILES OF
CANALS PIPELINES RESERVOIRS AND
HYDROELECTRIC POWER FACILITIES
THAT DELIVER WATER TO ITS
CUSTOMERS. THIS COMPLEX WATER
GRID IS ACTUALLY THE LARGEST
STATE OWNED AND OPERATED WATER
DELIVERY SYSTEM IN THE WORLD.
AND DR CALIFORNIA'S QUALITY OF
LIFE AND ECONOMIC VITALITY.
ADAPTING AND UPDATING THE SIX
YEAR OLD SYSTEM IS ESSENTIAL TO
BUILDING A MORE RESILIENT WATER
SUPPLY FOR THE FUTURE. ONE THAT
CAN WITHSTAND THE LONG LASTING
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
THROUGH CHARGES FOR
PARTICIPATION IN THE STATE
WATER PROJECT MY MEMBERS HAVE
FUNDED AND CONTINUE TO FUND.
ALL CAPITAL PROJECTS OPERATIONS
AND MAINTENANCE OF THE STATE
WATER PROJECT. AN EXTENSIVE
ECOSYSTEM RESTORATION. THE
EFFICIENT AND TIMELY DELIVERY
OF PROJECTS AND IMPROVEMENTS TO
EXISTING FACILITIES IS CRITICAL
TO THE STATE WATER PROJECT AT
ALL OF THE WATER USERS THAT
REPRESENTS. AS SUCH WE STRONGLY
SENATOR DODD. PROJECTS USING
DESIGN BUILD OR CONSTRUCTION
MANAGER GENERAL CONTRACTOR
PROCUREMENT METHODS. CAN BEGIN
EARLIER AND AVOID DELAYS
BECAUSE OF OVERLAPPING DESIGN
AND CONSTRUCTION PHASES. CAN
HELP REDUCE PROJECT RISKS AND
OVERALL COST OF WATER REPAIRS.
AND WILL SUPPORT D. W. R. IN
EXPEDITING CRITICAL WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE. MAINTENANCE AND
UPGRADES TO IMPROVE THE CLIMATE
RESILIENCY OF CALIFORNIA'S
WATER SUPPLY. EXAMPLES OF
PROJECTS THAT COULD UTILIZE THE
TWO PROCUREMENT METHODS
AUTHORIZED IN SB SIX TWO SIX
INCLUDE. IMPROVEMENTS TO RIVER
VALVE OUTLET THAT ARE BILL DAM.
UPGRADES TO NORTH AND SOUTH BAY
ATHLETIC FACILITIES MODERNIZING
SECURITY FACILITIES SUBSIDENCE
REPAIRS AND UPGRADES TO POWER
PLANTS. DO YOU HAVE YOUR ALSO
HAS OVER A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE DAM SAFETY PROJECTS UNDER
WAY OR IN THE QUEUE. IT IS
CRITICAL THAT YOU HAVE YOU ARE
HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO PURSUE
EFFICIENCIES TO COMPLETE THIS
WORK. IN CLOSING I WANT TO
THANK SENATOR DODD FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP AND FOR INTRODUCING
SB SIXTY SIX. ON BEHALF THE
STATE WATER CONTRACTORS IN THE
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION RATEPAYERS
AN AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY SIR BY
THE STATE WATER PROJECT WE ARE
DRIVE OUT THANKS AGAIN FOR YOUR
TIME THE AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU SEE THAT
THE NEXT WITNESSES ON THE-
TELEPHONE SERVICE MODERATOR.
CHENEY GOT ALL YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU I'M HERE- AS
THE ACTING- CHIEF ENGINEERING
MANAGER OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES AND INVALUABLE
TO ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS- IF
ANYONE HAS THEM THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I'LL ASK
NOW IF THERE ARE ANY.
INDIVIDUALS HERE WITH US- IN
SUPPORT PLEASE TAKE NAME. AND
POSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN BIRDS OF THE COMMITTEE
KATHY VIA TELEWEST THE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
REGULAR MUCH ANYONE ELSE HERE-
WE SHOULD TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR THE- YOU SEE NO ONE ANYONE
IN THE CONFERENCE ROOM WISHING
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
NO COMING FORWARD ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE WISHING TO. SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE. COMMENT IN THE
PORT OF SB SIX TWO SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. LINE
EIGHTY THREE LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CAROLYN JENSEN I'M
BEHALF OF THE MOJAVE WATER
AGENCY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PERSON. LINE
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS FOR CAL
I GALA WAS FREED GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS ON BEHALF OF DENTURE
WATER AGENCIES SUPPORT. YOU.
NINE FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBER
MODELING COOPER FROM THE OPEN
MARKET WE'RE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIA WE
REMAIN IN A SUPPORTIVE AMENDED
POSITION AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHORS THANK YOU. YOU.
LINE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER SHARON MEMBERS ANTHONY
MONNING ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA
CLARITA VALLEY WATER AGENCY IN
THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE SEVENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS OF
ELDORADO ON BEHALF IT HAD A
LITTLE BADLY THESE KERN WATER
AGENCY AND COURT. ONE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN BURST ON
THE START OF THE BALKAN GROUP
ON BEHALF OF OUR CLIENTS KERN
COUNTY WATER AGENCY A TIMBRE TO
DINO ALLOWING THIS FALL WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. M. LINE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS CHRIS CON
REPRESENTING THE COACHELLA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT AND SPORT
THANK YOU. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE TO COMMENTED
SUPPORT THANK YOU WE DO HAVE-
ONE GROUP. REGISTERED TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION- AND THEY
ARE DOING SO VIA TELEPHONE
PLEASE. ARGUMENT. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TYLER FUNDING ON
BEHALF. OF ENGINEERING
COMPANIES CALIFORNIA. MR MONTHS
IS THERE ANY WAY FOR YOU TO
STEP CLOSER TO THE MICROPHONE
IT IS- EXTREMELY SOFT. AT TWO
O'CLOCK MISTER SPECULATE THAT
THAT. THANK YOU I'D LIKE
TRANSACTION FIVE UNTIL BUT YEAH
REPORTER MARK AND ONE. THE BILL
ALREADY CONTAINS OTHER PARTS OF
THE GENERATOR. REPORTING FROM
WASHINGTON WHERE. HERE THAT I
CAN DATA AT ALL COMMITTEE TO
DEVELOP. PROCUREMENT THE BILL.
BY NOW TALK TO THE AUTHOR
MARTIN IS THE PLACE FOR MOM WE
ARE WE CAN HEAR THIS. INTENTIA
I ACTUALLY CLEAR USE AND THEN
YOU NEED BETWEEN COST OF HAVE
THE PUBLIC TO THIS BURKE. SEVEN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR TO YOU WE
HAVE NO WITH. WALLIAMS THAT MAX
HE'S GETTING CLOSE IN. NOT AT
IN FACT THE ONLY- SAID SO
TWENTY YEARS AGO AT THAT POINT
IT'S NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
VOTER GUIDE ANALYSIS PROP TWO
TO FOUR BUT YOU VERY SOME COST
COMPARISON. AS ASTOUNDING
SECTION FIVE THIS BILL IT NOW
SEES IT NOT THE TRUE APPLES AND
OF TOTAL. MISTER MONICA HERE
AND. I TO SECTOR. WHERE IS THE
PROHIBITS THIS PENSION SEVENTY
QUESTIONS INCLUDING. MORE CON.
BETWEEN HERE TRYING THAT PERSON
FOR ON ANY. ACTORS SUCH AS- TO
PARAPHRASE SUCH FIVE OF THE-
ANY OF THE COSTA CANNOT BE
DIRECT AND SOLELY ATTRIBUTABLE
TO THOSE STATE ENGINE. WORKING
IN THE SPECIFIC PROJECTS. SO
WHAT CAN WE ASK THE POINT OF
HAVING THE- ANNUALLY GEN.
ACCOUNTING THE DAILY AS YEARS
AGO. LESS THAN. IN PICTURE OF
THE TWO COST. OF THE PUBLIC
VERSUS SECTOR ENGINEERS. AGAIN
WE AGREE WITH RANGING
DEPARTMENT DESIGNED SEEM TO
STATE. WE CANNOT IN THE PUBLIC
NOT. EX THIS MISLEADING REPORT
PART OF THE PART. OR ANY PUBLIC
ENTITY FOR THAT MATTER.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR THESE REASONS
MISTER SPARKLY OPPOSE SB. SIX
TWO SIX THANKS VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL WE'LL OTHER. FOR
THAT WE DID. MAYBE THE LAST
FORTY SECONDS OF MISTER
MARCHING THROUGH. TESTIMONY
PERHAPS WE CAN COMMUNICATE WITH
HIM TO GET. HIS TESTIMONY IN
WRITING TO SUBMITTED AND FOR
THE RECORD. AND AND LET HIM
KNOW THAT SO THAT THAT HE IS
AWARE SO WE ONLY CAUGHT. A
PORTION OF IT- LAST TO SEE IF
THERE IS ANYONE IN THE ROOM ARE
WISHING TO TESTIFY AGAINST. IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. ANYONE
IN THE CONFERENCE ROOM. OKAY
WE'LL GO TO THE- PHONE LINES-
MISTER MODERATOR BEFORE- WE
OPEN IT UP FOR QUESTIONS.
ANYONE WISHING TO COMMENT IN IN
OPPOSITION. TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX TWO SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. THERE'S
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU- WE WILL
NOW BRING IT TO THE FLOOR I SEE
A COUPLE MIKES THAT HAVE BEEN
IFTED UP. SUMMER THANK THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN I WAS WONDERING
IF I CAN ASK A QUESTION A
COUPLE QUESTIONS TO THE
DEPARTMENT PLEASES SOMEONE
TONIGHT IF SOMEONE OF
DEPARTMENT IS AVAILABLE YES
THERE'S A SO- IT APPEARS THAT
SECTION FIVE IS ATTEMPTING TO
GET A COMPARING THE COST OF THE
DEPARTMENT USING PRIVATE
CONSULTANTS TO PERFORM THE
ENGINEERING ON THESE PROJECT
VERSUS USING DEPARTMENT
ENGINEERS TO PERFORM THIS WORK.
AND IF MY QUESTION CAN COME
AFTER I CONFERENCE I'VE- SO YOU
KNOW I'VE LOOKED AT THE L. A.
ANALYSIS THAT WAS REFERENCED
EARLIER AND IF I REMEMBER
CORRECTLY- ABOUT THOSE MISSING
COSTS WHEN THIS WAS REPORTED
BACK IN THOUGH IN THE NINETEEN
NINETY A BALLOT. INITIATIVE ONE
DENOUNCES WOULD NOT REFLECT A
TO APPLES TO APPLES COMPARISON
OF TOTAL COSTS. TO COST FACTORS
ON THE PUBLIC SIDE THAT WERE
AND LIGHTLY OR UNCERTAIN TO BE
COUNTED IN THE TOTAL COSTS
INCLUDED ONE STATE AGENCY
OVERHEAD COSTS WHICH IS. TOP
MANAGEMENT. TO OTHERS STATE
AGENCY OVERHEAD COSTS SUCH AS
PAYROLL ACCOUNTING AND
PERSONNEL FUNCTIONS THREE
HIRING AND TRAINING CLASSES FOR
ANY ADDITIONAL STATE EMPLOYEES
NEEDED TO PERFORM A SERVICE.
FOR INCREASED CONSTRUCTION
COSTS IS ASSOCIATE WOULD
PROJECTS DELAYS CAUSED BY TIME
NEEDED TO HIRE AND TRAIN
ADDITIONAL STATE EMPLOYEES- THE
LAST ONE IS COSTS OF
MAINTAINING EXCESSIVE STATE
STAFF IF WORKLOAD DECLINES SO
THE QUESTION WOULD BE IS THAT
SO WOULD IT BE ACCURATE TO SAY
THAT SECTION FIVE REPORTING
THIS BILL IS ASKING D. W. R. TO
GIVE THE LOWEST CASE ESTIMATE
ON THE COST OF USING STATE
EMPLOYEES AND THE HIGHEST CASE
ESTIMATE FOR USE A PRIVATE.
ENGINEERS AND THEN SECOND IS-
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE IT'S A FAIR
APPLES TO APPLES COMPARISON TO
YOU. SCOUT WILLIS YEAH I THINK
THAT THREATENS THEM IS CUTTING
ANY TITLE. YEAH AND YEAH I
AGREE THAT- THAT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT YOU MENTIONED
ARE- NOT INCLUDING ALL OF THE
**** THANK YOU- AGAIN INSIDE
AND- THAT AS IT IS WRITTEN- BUT
THE DEPARTMENT WERE WILLING TO
PROVIDE WHATEVER COSTS ARE-
REQUESTED IN THE LEGISLATION.
THE MAY I ADD TO THE LIKE TO
FALL BUT IF YOU LOOK AT PAGE
TWENTY NINE NINETEEN IT'S VERY
SPECIFIC THAT THE ONLY COST YOU
CAN COUNT OUTSIDE SELLING
BENEFITS THOSE DIRECTLY AND
SOLELY AT TO BE ABLE TO THOSE
STATE ENGINEERS WORKING ON
THESE PROJECTS. AND THAT GOES
SAME WITH LYING TWENTY ON THE
PRIVATE ENGINEERS SITE AS WELL
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE
DO AT ALL THE CLASSES BECAUSE
YOU KNOW THEN THAT WAY JUST
GIVES US A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
OF THE TRUE COSTS AND YOU KNOW
WHAT IS BEST. BUT GOING FORWARD
AND MAKING SURE THAT THE
PROJECT IS DONE CORRECTLY AND
THAT IT'S ALSO- NO NOT UNDER
ESTIMATED OR UNDER COSTS- SO
THAT WE MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE WE
HAVE EVERYTHING UP FRONT AND
TRANSPARENT. DO YOU THINK THAT
IT'S A FAIR APPLES TO APPLES
COMPARISON THEN. THE WAY IT'S
WRITTEN. WITH SECTION. FIVE NO
IT IS NOT A COKE IT IS NOT A-
CURRENTLY HAS WRITTEN IS NOT AN
APPLE TO APPLE COMPARISON FOR
THAT THE REASON YOU CAN
MENTION. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. YES MISTER SENATOR
DODD SO THAT WAS ALSO MY
CONCERN AS SECTION FIVE- I DO
APPRECIATE THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL WHICH IS TO LOWER COSTS
AND INCREASES IN FISSION SEATS
ON CAPITAL PROJECTS- MOVING
FORWARD ARE YOU WILLING TO LOOK
AT THOSE ARE TAKE AMENDMENTS.
IN REGARDS TO SECTION FIVE. THE
IS AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED
PEOPLE THAT KNOW ME-
PARTICULARLY IN THIS ROOM I'M
ALWAYS WILLING TO- TO LISTEN TO
ARGUMENTS AND ALSO SOLUTIONS TO
MAKE THIS BILL BETTER. THANK
YOU. SIX SO LIKE TO MAKE A
MOTION TO APPROVE THE BILL WITH
AMENDMENTS STRIKING SECTION
FIVE FROM THIS BILL BECAUSE
THAT IS MY BIG CONCERN WITH HIS
BILL TO IF YOU'RE IF YOU CAN GO
WITH THAT- IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THAT WE
NEED TO EVALUATE BUT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT SAYING THAT IT IS A
FLAWED REPORT. WHAT MORE
REASONS DO WE NEED BUT TERRIBLE
GOVERNMENTS. TO APPROVE A BILL
BUT IF YOU'RE WILLING TO TAKE
SECTION OF MY MOTION IS TO
PROVE IT WAS SECTION FIVE TAKEN
OUT. THERE IS A MOTION. OKAY
THE SECOND FOR DISCUSSION
PURPOSES. REMISSION WITHIN THE
LONGER. YES WITH WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
I CONSIDER THAT A HOSTILE
AMENDMENT- I REALLY BELIEVE
THAT- THESE BILLS COULD BE
ANALYZED MUCH MORE EFFECTIVELY
BY HAVING STAFF LOOK AT LET'S
LOOK AT WHAT THE RAMIFICATIONS
ARE WE DO NOT HAVE ALL THE
INFORMATION AND ALL THE
ANALYSIS TO DO THAT ON THE
FLOOR TODAY IN MY OPINION AND-
I DRIVE I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK. FOR THE BILL TO BE PASSED
AS IS. THE FURTHER UP CAN I GET
A COMMITMENT THAT WE WILL LOOK
AT SECTION FIVE. AS IT MOVES
FORWARD BECAUSE I'M SUPPORTIVE
OF THE BILL. BUT IT'S JUST
SECOND FIVE THAT I HAVE A
CONCERN WITH AZAR OF RETIRED
CONTRACTOR. WHEN WE ARE GONNA
SOLIDIFY JUST ONE DEPARTMENT
BEING ABLE TO WORK OUT IT
SHOULD BE BE ABLE TO GO
OUTSIDE. THE TO MAKE THE
PROJECTS GO QUICKER IF WHAT I'M
SEVEN MEMBER I WOULD SET
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY. ASK ME
THE QUESTION I SAID YES THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT- I I'M WILLING
TO HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS. MOVE
SO THE- I THINK MISTER SMITH
SAID MOVE THE BILL HE HAS
MOTION. THEIR SECOND TO MOVE
THE BILL AS AS PRESENTED
THERE'S A SECOND WOMEN'S
FRIEDMAN IS A COMMITMENT BY THE
AUTHOR TO WORK ON THE SECTION
FIVE LANGUAGE IT'S BEEN-
DISCUSS DARN ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ALL LAST
THE- TO. ALL THE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU- MISTER DOCTOR. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA
HI EDUARDO GARCIA HI DOLLY
NONVOTING DOLLY NOT VOTING
BENNETT BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOT
VOTING FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I KALRA COLORADO LEVINE.
MURATSUCHI AND WHEN. AND WHEN
NOT VOTING RUBIO RUBIO AYE
SALAS. SMITH. VIPTELA VIA
PADURA HI WARD WARD I. OKAY
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR THE
MEMBERS AT ALL AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT- YOU WILL BE PRESENTING
FOR CENTER STERN SB SEVEN
NINETY THE BILL DOES HAVE A
RIGHT TO PASS RECOMMENDATION
PLEASE PROCEED YES THIS CHAIRED
MEMBERS- CENTER STERN HAD TO
TAKE A FLIGHT AND I WAS THE
LUCKY ONE THAT WAS IN THE ROOM
THAT HE ASKED BOB SO TURN
MEMBERS SB SEVEN NINETY WILL
MAKE SURE THAT OUR CITIZENS
WILDLIFE AND ROADS ARE BETTER
PROTECTED. THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE A NEW COMPUTER
COMPENSATORY MITIGATION CREDIT
PROGRAM AT CDFW FOR CALTRANS
PROJECTS IMPROVE WILDLIFE
CONNECTIVITY AMONG OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL- IMPROVEMENTS
THIS WILL GIVE DE THAT DFW AND
DOT THE ABILITY TO WORK
TOGETHER TO MAKE WILDLIFE
CROSSINGS PROJECTS A HIGHER
PRIORITY AND MORE COMMON
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. DUE TO
NATURAL EVENTS SUCH AS FIRES
DROUGHT AND FLOODING VARIOUS
SPECIES OF THE IMPACT OF THE
SAME EVENTS ON WILDLIFE ARE
OFTEN OVERLOOKED IN RECENT
YEARS THE CHANGING FACE OF OUR
STATE HAS RESULTED IN CHANGING
MIGRATION PATTERNS AND HABITATS
FIRST SO MUCH OF CALIFORNIA'S
WILD WILDLIFE THE WILDLIFE
VEHICLE COLLISIONS REPORTED IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ALONE
COST THREE HUNDRED FOURTEEN
INSTANCES OF INJURY. AN
ESTIMATED FIVE DEATHS IN OVER
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL
COSTS. THAT IS IN LEAD ONE AT.
CROSSING STRUCTURE ON A HIGHWAY
DIVIDING HABITAT AREAS MAY BE
SUFFICIENT TO MAINTAIN JEAN
FULLER FLOW AND MULE DEER
MOUNTAIN LIONS OF TOUCHING
OTHER SPECIES WHICH UNDERSCORES
THE CONTINUED RELEVANCY- OF
WILDLIFE CROSSINGS A CONNECTIVE
ITTY ACROSS URBAN MAJORS IS- IT
IS CRITICAL THAT WE TAKE STEPS
TO ENSURE THAT WILDLIFE CAN
MIGRATE SAFELY TO PREVENT
FURTHER HARM TO CALIFORNIA'S
UNIQUE BIODIVERSITY. AS WELL AS
PREVENT ADDITIONAL HARBOR
CALIFORNIA'S RESIDENTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL MINDANAO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THERE'S A
MOTION AND A SECOND ON THE BILL
WE DO HAVE. A WITNESS- TWO
WITNESSES VIA TELEPHONE WELL A
PLEASE MISTER MODERATOR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR READ OUT US
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBERS
AND THANK YOU SENATOR DOCTOR
PRESENTING READ OUT OF SUNDAY
HAPPENED MOUNTAINS RECREATION
AND CONSERVATION AUTHORITY.
MRCA IS DEDICATED TO THE
PRESERVATION AND MANAGEMENT OF
LOCAL OPEN SPACE AND WILDLIFE
HABITAT. WE HAVE DIRECT
EXPERIENCE DEALING WITH
WILDLIFE MOVEMENT BETWEEN THE
SANTA MONICA BEACH SIERRA MADRE
MOUNTAIN RANGES. THAT IS WHY
WE'REIN SUPPORT HERE TODAY
BECAUSE THIS BILL HELPS US
ADDRESS A CRITICAL PROBLEM.
BOTH FOR WILDLIFE AS THEY MOVE
IN UNFORTUNATELY SOMETIMES HAVE
TO MOVE ACROSS ROADWAYS. ARE
GETTING KILLED. IN ADDITION BY
HELPING REDUCE THE NUMBER AND
THE TYPES OF ANIMALS CROSSING
THESE ROADWAYS WERE ALSO
HELPING WITH PUBLIC SAFETY. SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE TO SOLUTION
OR AN INCENTIVE FOR CALTRANS TO
WANT TO PARTICIPATE IN
MODIFYING ROADWAYS WHERE WE'VE
IDENTIFIED IT AS A WILDLIFE
CORRIDOR. THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY KEYS OFF OF AN
IMPORTANT IMHO USE THAT WAS
DESIGNED FOR A WIDE LIKE
CROSSING ON HIGHWAY SEVENTEEN
IN THE SANTA CRUZ OUR REGION.
IT PROVIDES EXPLICIT AUTHORITY
TO CDFW AND CALTRANS TO BE ABLE
TO WORK TOGETHER TO RECEIVE
THESE MITIGATION CREDITS. IT
PROVIDES A VERY SIMPLE TOOL
THAT CAN BE USED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. WITH THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENT IT ALSO
ALLOWS FOR BETTER PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION AND EFFICIENCY.
AND ULTIMATELY TO MAKE SURE WE
ARE NOT OVERWHELMING THE STATE
THERE'S A PROJECT CAN OCCUR AT
A YEAR CAPS IN THE BILL. FOR
THOSE REASONS WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT TODAY AND REQUEST YOUR
I. BROKE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISS LAND GRAB YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK
LANDGRAF EXTERNAL AFFAIRS
MANAGER AT THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY OPEN SPACE AUTHORITY
WHICH IS AN INDEPENDENT SPECIAL
DISTRICT THAT'S PRESERVED OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND ACRES OF
NATURAL WORKING LANDS.
PROTECTING THREATENED AND
ENDANGERED SPECIES IN THE SANTA
CLARA VALLEY. I'M HONORED TO BE
HERE AND EXPRESSED STRONG
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF OUR AGENCY
FOR SENATE BILL SEVEN NINETY BY
SENATOR STERN. THE OPEN SPACE
AUTHORITY THAT'S PARTNERS ARE
WORKING TO PROTECT AND ENHANCE
A VITAL WILDLIFE CORRIDOR IN
THE SANTA CLARA VALLEY. BETWEEN
THE SANTA CRUZ MOUNTAINS AND
THE DIABLO RANGE WHICH TOGETHER
REPRESENT OVER THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN CONSERVATION BASSMAN
FROM THE STATE. FEDERAL
AGENCIES LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
PRIVATE PHILANTHROPY. KILEY
BALLY'S THE LAST PUZZLE PIECE
THAT CONNECTS OVER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES OF PROTECTED
OPEN SPACE ALONG LILAC MOVEMENT
THAT SORT OF SO CRITICAL IN THE
PACE OF CLIMATE CHANGE. OUR
GOAL IS TO IMPROVE MOTORIST
SAFETY BY REDUCING POTENTIAL
COLLISIONSWITH WILDLIFE. AND
MAINTAIN HEALTHY WILDLIFE
POPULATIONS THROUGH HABITAT
CONNECTIVITY ALSO PROTECTING
AND RESTORING NATURAL
FLOODPLAINS IMPROVING WATER
QUALITY. AND HELPING TO BUILD A
CLIMATE RESILIENT FUTURE FOR
RESIDENTS OF THE SOUTH BAY. OUR
SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
PROVIDES. FOR CALTRANS TO
CONTRIBUTE TO IMPORTANT
PROJECTS LIKE THESE WHICH WILL
BENEFIT WILDLIFE AND HUMANS
ALIKE. THE BILL HAS A WIDE
RANGE OF SUPPORTERS AND IS
HEAVILY SUPPORTED BY THE WALLET
CORNER WORKING GROUP THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF
WILDLIFE AND HABITAT
CONNECTIVITY ADVOCATES. AND
WE'RE WORKING WITH CALTRANS OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE TO WORK OUT THE
DETAILS OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME I THANK
SENATOR STERN FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP AND I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK- IN
SUPPORT OF BILL HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS PLEASE. REPORT YES
MISTER CHAIRMAN MARC SMITH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION AND THE
BACKCOUNTRY HUNTERS AND ANGLERS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HI ANYWHERE
ELSE HERE THE CHAMBER SUPPORT.
SEE NO ONE IN THE VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM. NO ONE. ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINES AS
MODERATORS PART. TO COME IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN NINETY
PLEASE POST WHAT THEM ZERO. AND
LINE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ANASTASIA
CULTURE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ADVENTURES ON BEHALF OF VENTURA
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN NINETY THANK YOU. YOU IN
LINE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON NATALIE NOT GOING TO
HAVE TO RANCHO SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY MATANZA REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT NATURE FOR ALL
ESCONDIDO CREEK CONSERVANCY
PLANNING AND CONSERVATION
LEAGUE AND NATIONAL WILDLIFE
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT. LINE
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NEWMAN CHAIR MEMBERS PERSONAL
DOCTOR BEHALF OF THE HUMANE
SOCIETY UNITED IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE LOST LNE EIGHTY FIVE
IF YOU WISH TO REACH YOU ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME FOR SUPPORT.
LINE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
BALKANS OFFICE ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AT THOUSAND OAKS AND
SUPPORT. THERE ARE NO OTHER
LINES IN SUPPORT. MISTER KERR
IS GO AHEAD THANK YOU I DON'T
HAVE ANYONE REGISTERED TO-
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION ALL I ASK
OF TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
HERE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION IN
THE CHAMBERS SEE ANYONE EITHER
ANYONE IN THE VIDEO CONFERENCE
ROOM- NO ONE FIVE COMING
FORWARD ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES MISTER MODERATOR TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. TO SPEAK IT. TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN
NINETY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. THERE ARE NO LINES IN THE
QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVEN NINETY THANK YOU ALL AND
BRING BACK TO THE FLOOR AS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SAY
ENOUGH YES- SUMMER SIERRA.
THANK YOU I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT. OF MR STERN IS DEAN
THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING FOR
HIM I TRIED TO MAKE A COPY OF
COMMON FOR CALTRANS SAYS
HOPEFULLY. LISTENING THESE ARE
GREAT PROJECTS I HAVE. A COUPLE
OF FREEWAY ENTRANCES. AND TO
GET TO WALK ACROSS ACROSS THEM
FEELS LIKE YOU'RE GOING TO LOSE
YOUR LIFE AS A CONSTITUENT. WE
HAVE GOT FORMER GOVERNOR OF
BROWN DOWN THERE VISITING AND-
CROSS ONE OF THE OVERPASSES
THIS SECURITY STOP ME IS THAT
THIS IS TOO DANGEROUS WHENI
GET A LITTLE CROSS THE NEXT
ONES. INSIDE HOPE AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT BRIDGES FOR WILDLIFE
FOR THIS YEAR TO HAVE SAFE
LOCK- FRIEND WITH THE HAVE SAVE
WALKWAYS ROUGH LOOKING AT-
BRIDGES FOR PEDESTRIANS IN
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE TO HAVE
SAFE WALKWAYS TO GET ACROSS.
FROM ONE SIDE OF THE FREEWAY TO
THE OTHER. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEE NO
ONE- WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND ALREADY. SO THAT WE DO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EITHER
THANK YOU WILL CALL QUESTION
YOUR WITH SECTOR. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE. EDUARDO GARCIA HI
EDUARDO GARCIA HI DOLLY. DOLLY
I BENNETT BIGELOW. BIGELOW HI
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN HI CRISTINA
GARCIA. KALRA KALRA I. LEVINE.
MURATSUCHI NO ONE NO WHEN I
RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS SMITH.
SMITH I'D BE ABLE TO DO IT VIA
PADU OD WARD WARD I. CRISTINA
GARCIA I. ALL RIGHT WE'LL LEAVE
THAT OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO
ADD ON AND A COUPLE OF PEOPLE
TO STEP OUT THANK YOU SENATOR
WE HAVE ONE BILL LEFT AND
SPREAD FOR CENTER PROFFERED SB
SEVEN NINETY SIX PLEASE PROCEED
YOU DO HAVE A SUPPORT
RECOMMENDATIONS. THE MOTION OF
LARGE SECOND RIGHT I RESPECT
BESSER EITHER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOU HAVE A ONE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M STANDING
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT SB SEVEN
NINE SIX I WANT TO FIRST THANK
THE COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIRMAN
JOB AMENDMENTS TO BETTER
COLLECT. CLARIFY THE TAX
EXEMPTION- SB SEVEN NINE SIX.
REPRESENTS S. STORABLE. MISTER
JUSTICE ARE IN JUST AS I SHOULD
SAY THAT WAS PLACED UPON.
AFRICAN AMERICAN FAMILY ALMOST
A HUNDRED YEARS AGO. CHARLES
AND WILL OF BRUCE PURCHASE A
PIECE OF PROPERTY IN MANHATTAN
BEACH IN NINETEEN TWELVE SIMPLY
TO LIVE OUT THE AMERICAN DREAM.
TO SIMPLY PROVIDE A SEPARATE
BUT EQUAL OPPORTUNITY FOR
AFRICAN AMERICANS DIRECTORY AND
ENJOY BEACH LIFE JUST LIKE
ANYONE ELSE. BUT IN NINETEEN
TWELVE THE PURCHASES PROPERTY.
OPEN UP A BEACH HOUSE A
RESTAURANT A DANCE HALL- AND IT
DRIVES. IT DRIVE FOR TWELVE
YEARS DESPITE THE RACIST
ATTACKS ON BOTH THE BRUCE
FAMILY AND THE SIX OTHER
FAMILIES TO PURCHASE PROPERTY
THERE BY NOT ONLY LOCAL
RESIDENTS BUT THE KKK AND AFTER
TWELVE YEARS OF. VICIOUS
RACISTS ATTACKS WHEN THAT
WASN'T ABLE TO DRIVE THE
BRUISES AND THE SIX OTHER
FAMILIES OFF THE LAND THE CITY
OF MANHATTAN BEACH INTERCEDED
TO STEAL THIS LAND. THROUGH
EMINENT DOMAIN. THEY FORCED THE
FAMILIES TO SELL THEIR PROPERTY
UNDER THE GUISE THAT THEY
NEEDED TO BUILD A PARK. WELL WE
STAND HERE TODAY AND THERE'S
STILL NO PARK AT BRUCE'S BEACH
YES THERE IS A MONUMENT AND
THERE'S A BATCH. BUT THERE'S
NEVER THE PART THAT WAS
PROMISED AND AFTER OVER TWENTY
PLUS YEARS OF OCCUPYING THE
PROPERTY. THEY DEEDED OVER TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
AGAIN AFTER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA POSSESSING A
PROPERTY FOR ALMOST FIFTY YEARS
THERE WERE STILL. NO PARK BUILT
AND THAT'S WHEN THE- STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- IN NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE DEEDED THE PROPERTY OVER
TO THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES WE
STAND HERE TODAY WORKING IN
CONCERT WITH THIS. STATE COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES THE FREE THEIR
HANDS TO ALLOW THE COUNTY TO
RETURN THIS PROPERTY BACK. TO
THE HEIRS OF CHARLES AND WILL
LOOK BRUCE IT'S THE RIGHT THING
TO DO IT'S NOT A GIFT THE
PUBLIC FUNDS AND THE SAD THING
IS THIS IS NOT UNIQUE. THERE'S
HUNDREDS OF NOT THOUSANDS OF
EXAMPLES OF WORK AFTER
AMERICANS. WERE DEPRIVED OF
THEIR PROPERTY SIMPLY BECAUSE
OF RACIST HATE AND JUST. JUST
THE FACT THAT THEY JUST THEY'RE
WALKING. THEM IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND THEY USE THE
LAW TO COMMIT CRIMES. RED ZONE
IN IT AND REDLINING I SHOULD
SAY AND THINGS OF THAT NATURE
AND I STAND HERE TODAY YOU'RE
ON JULY FIRST. AND IN MY
DISTRICT. IN THE COMMUNITY-
WHAT'S WHERE THERE'S BEEN THE
HAWKINS HOUSE OF BURGERS THAT
IT EXISTED FOR EIGHTY YEARS.
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION IS
MALPRACTICE TO RUN THAT FAMILY
OFF A PIECE OF LAND. THAT THEY
HAVE HAD A BUSINESS FOR EIGHTY
YEARS PRIOR TO THE ONE OH FIVE
FREEWAY SPLITTING THE COMMUNITY
OF WHAT'S- THIRTY PLUS YEARS
AGO SO WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
BRUCE FAMILY IS HAPPENING TODAY
TO THE HAWKING FAMILY AND
WATCHED AND IT'S NOT USED AND
WE SHOULD SAY ENOUGH IS ENOUGH
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO DO THE RIGHT THING. AND
RETURN THIS PROPERTY TO THE
BRUCE FAMILY AND WE CAN
DEMONSTRATE WHAT REDEMPTION
LOOKS LIKE A MORE POORLY WERE
REPARATIONS LOOK LIKE AND WHAT
JUSTICE CAN LOOK LIKE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BELIEVE I HAVE
ONLINE SUPERVISOR JANICE HAHN
WHO IS SPEARHEADED THIS THROUGH
THE COUNTY AND I WANT TO THANK
HER FOR HER COURAGEOUS
LEADERSHIP AS WELL AS OUR
FORMER COLLEAGUE CAN BOTH OF
THESE HOUSES. SUPERVISOR HOLLY
MITCHELL. THANK YOU. MR
MODERATOR PLEASE SUCCULENT.
JANICE ON YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS ACTUALLY
KILEY CODES- I'M THE JUSTICE
DEPUTY FOR SUPERVISOR JANICE
HAHN UNFORTUNATELY SUPERVISOR
HAHN WAS UNABLE TO MAKE IT
TODAY BUT SHE STRONGLY SUPPORTS
I READ HER TESTIMONY ON HER
BEHALF. I WANT TO START BY
THANKING SENATOR STEVEN
BRADFORD FOR OFFERING SENATE
BILL SEVEN NINE SIX AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AL MURATSUCHI
FOR ALL HIS SUPPORT AND FOR
BEING A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR ON
THE SCALE. I GREW UP IN L. A.
COUNTY MY WHOLE LIFE WITH THE
FAMILY DEEPLY INVOLVED IN LOCAL
POLITICS. AND YET I'M
EMBARRASSED TO SAY THAT I
DIDN'T HEAR THE HISTORY OF
BREEZES BEACH UNTIL LAST YEAR.
I'VE GROWN UP THINKING THAT THE
JIM CROW SEGREGATIONIST
POLICIES OF THE SOUTH DID NOT
HAPPEN HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THAT FOR THE MOST PART OF
CALIFORNIANS WERE CLEAN OF SUCH
A RACIST PAST. BUT THAT WASN'T
TRUE. THE STORY BRIDGES BEACH
IS THE STORY OF THE AMERICAN
DREAM BEING STOLEN FROM
HARDWORKING AFRICAN AMERICAN
FAMILY JUST BECAUSE OF THEIR
RACE. A LAWFUL DRIVING BUSINESS
THAT PROVIDED AFRICAN AMERICANS
ACCESS TO THE BEACH WAS
INTENTIONALLY SHUT DOWN BY THE
CITY GOVERNMENT WITH THE
INTENTION OF DRIVING OUT BLACK
FAMILIES AND BLACK BEACH GOERS.
WHAT HAPPENED TO WILL AND
CHARLES BRUCE ALMOST ONE
HUNDRED YEARS AGO WAS A GREAT
INJUSTICE THAT WAS NOT ONLY
INFLICTED ON THEM BUT ALSO ON
GENERATIONS OF THEIR
DESCENDANTS ALMOST CERTAINLY
WOULD HAVE BEEN MILLIONAIRES
HAD THEY BEEN ABLE TO KEEP
THEIR PROPERTY. I WHILE WE
CANNOT CHANGE THE PAST WE
SHOULD DO EVERYTHING IN OUR
POWER IN THE PRESIDENT TO CRACK
THIS HISTORIC INJUSTICE. WHEN I
FOUND OUT THAT L. A. COUNTY
CURRENTLY OWNS THE LAND THAT
WAS- THAT WAS ONCE BRIDGES
BEACH I KNEW IMMEDIATELY THAT
WE HAD TO GIVE IT BACK. TODAY
THIS LAND IS THE SITE O THE LA
COUNTY LIFEGUARD
ADMINISTRATION. BUILDING AND
THE ONLY WAY TO MAKE THIS RIGHT
IS TO TRANSFER THE LAND BACK TO
THE DESCENDANTS OF WILL AND
CHARLES BRUCE. L. A. COUNTY
INTENDS TO GIVE IT BACK AND WE
INTEND TO SHOW THE REST OF THE
STATE AND THE COUNTRY. BUT IT
IS POSSIBLE TO BEGIN TO MAKE
AMENDS. BUT WE NEED YOUR HELP.
WHEN THE STATE TRANSFER THE
LAND TO THE COUNTY IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE. IT CAME WITH
RESTRICTIONS. WE CAN'T TRANSFER
THE LAND BACK TO BRIDGETOWN THE
UNTIL THOSE RESTRICTIONS ARE
LIFTED. SO PLEASE HELP US RIGHT
THIS HISTORIC WRONG BY PASSING
SB SEVEN NINE SIX AND REMOVING
THE RESTRICTIONS ON BRIDGES
BEACH. THE L. A. COUNTY CAN
TRANSFER IT BACK TO ITS
RIGHTFUL OWNERS. THE
DESCENDANTS OF WILL AND CHARLES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WELL WE
HAVE ANOTHER PERSON CALLING IN
AS A WITNESS- THE CENTER SAID.
I ONLY HEAR TO SUPERVISOR
LISTED AS PRIMARY WITNESS OKAY.
FOR MODERATE. OKAY WITH. THERE
ANOTHER WITNESS TELEPORT. ALL
RIGHT THEN NOW WE'RE ASKING NOW
IS THERE ANYONE HERE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE BILL.
ANYONE IN THE VIDEO CONFERENCE
ROOM. ANYONE CONTENT TO JUST
ADD THE NAME ORGANIZATION FOR
SUPPORT ON THE TELEPHONE LINE.
FOR COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
LINE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
LEAH BARRETT IN STRONG SUPPORT
ON BEHALF OF EARTHY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CARE ACT ENSURE NUMBER THE
FISHING EGO ON BEHALF OF OUR
SCHOOLS LATINO OUTDOORS AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE PARKS NOW
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS
IS BOB NAYLOR I REPRESENT FIELD
SOUTHERN COMPANY THAT POWERED
AHMANSON JUNIOR A LIFELONG.
ADVOCATE AGAINST EMINENT- BASIC
DOMAIN ABUSE WHICH THIS WAS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SEVEN
NINETY SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU
NAME. ORGANIZATION POSITION
PLEASE. LINE FIFTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD WITH YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. LINE.
FIFTY FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
BRIAN STEIGER ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT SB
SEVEN NINETY SIX THANK YOU. AND
LINE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JENNIFER
POP THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN NINETY SIX THANK YOU. AND
MISTER CHAIR THERE'S NO FURTHER
SUPPORT IN THE QUEUE THANK YOU
LOS TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION I DON'T
HAVE ANY REGISTERED OPPOSITION
BUT LAS TO SEE IF ANYONE- IS-
HERE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SAY
NO ONE ANYONE THE- CONFERENCE
ROOM. NO ONE COMING FORWARD.
AND SO ANYONE IN THE- PHONE
LINE. TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
MISTER MODERATOR. TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN NINE SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. THERE'S
NO ONE IN OPPOSITION SB SEVEN
NINETY SIX THANK YOU FOR YOUR
BACK TO THE FLOOR WE HAVE A
COUPLE BIKES UP- SUMMER
FRIEDMAN. I JUST WANTED TO
THANK THE SENATOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD- THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BILL NOT
JUST FOR THE BRUCE'S BUT REALLY
TO SHOW WHAT. JUSTICE CAN LOOK
LIKE AND RESTORATIONS CAN LOOK
LIKE AND- I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'RE STILL TAKING ANY
AMENDMENTS BUT I'D BE VERY
PROUD TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR IF THAT'S A POSSIBILITY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS PLEASE.
THANK YOU- MAYBE FOR THE AUTHOR
TO HELP FOR A FOR ALL OF US TO
UNDERSTAND. THIS BILL IS A
LITTLE SILENT ON WHAT REALLY
THE NEXT STEPS ARE WITH RESPECT
TO THE ZONING. WHILE THIS LAND
WOULD BE RESTORED BACK TO THE
FAMILIES AND OFFER TO- AND
THERE WOULDN'T BE ANY STATE-
DIRECTION ON IT REMAINING AS A
PART. THERE STILL IS THE VOID
OF KNOWLEDGE OF KNOWING THAT
THEY WILL BE RESTORED TO WHAT
AT A USABLE ZONING WILL BE
THERE SO THEY'RE NOT LEFT
HANGING. WITH A PIECE OF LAND
THAT STILL CAN'T BE USED. SO
THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
UNDERSTANDING OF THAT AND MAYBE
YOU CAN ADD SOME CLARITY TO
THAT OR MAYBE THE SUPERVISORS
STAFFER COULD ADD SOME CLARITY
TO THAT. BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT I STILL SUPPORT THE
BILL THE- THROUGH THIS BUT I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT AS
WE GO THROUGH THIS WE DON'T
FORGET THE LITTLE DETAILS.
BECAUSE THAT'S IMPORTANT. I
TOTALLY AGREE AND CURRENTLY IT
IS OUR INTENTION TO AND THROUGH
THE COUNTY TO. RETURN THE
PROPERTY AS OWN CURRENTLY AND-
HOPEFULLY LEAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY. ALL WITH THE CITY
TO DO THE RIGHT THING THEY'RE
THE ONLY ONES WHO HAVE VOICED
THEIR OPPOSITION- TO RETURNING
THIS PROPERTY SADLY I MEAN. A
HUNDRED YEARS AFTER- THE CITY
STILL IN A PROPERTY THEIR STEEL
HAVE. DUG THEIR HEELS IN THE
SAND AT LEAST THE MAJORITY OF
THEIR COUNSEL. AND NOT ONE
APOLOGIZING TO THE FAMILY BUT
YEAH- LET ALONE. STATING THEIR
POSITION SO RIGHT NOW IT'S A
LIFEGUARD STATION- TRAINING
STATION THAT'S THERE. THE
COUNTY HAS COMMITTED TO A
CONTINUED PLAN LEAST AS IS.
UNTIL WE CAN WORK OUT THOSE
DETAILS SO IT WILL CONTINUE AS
THAT- UNTIL WE CAN. FURTHER
WORK THIS OUT AND WE ALSO WANT
TO MAKE CLEAR. WE THROUGH THAT
MA'AM IT'S TAKEN IN THIS
COMMITTEE IT ALSO PROTECTS THE
FAMILY FROM. THE DAYS- SAYS
VALUE SO THEY WOULD LOSE THEIR
PROPERTY IF IT WAS GIVEN BACK
TO HIM ACTED. TODAY'S ASSESSED
VALUE OF SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
IT'S NO WAY THEY COULD AFFORD
IT SO WE'RE MAKING SURE THAT
IT'S- RETURNED AT OP. POST OP
PRE I SHOULD SAY- PROP.
THIRTEEN VALUE AS WELL. HUH
SENIOR THE QUESTIONS ARE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH PRESENTING THIS
BILL- I WANTED TO SHARE WITH
YOU THAT- FOR MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF. THIS HAS BEEN
TRULY- SOMETHING VERY IMPORTANT
SPECIAL. AT VERY SIGNIFICANT
PIECE OF POLICY TO BE ABLE TO
WORK ON- GIVEN THE SUBSTANCE OF
THE MATTER- THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS ISSUE. AND SO- WE'RE VERY
GLAD THAT THIS CAME TO THIS
COMMITTEE. AND SO ON. I WILL
CALL THE QUESTION AND AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- SO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. A KURDISH
CLOSE MR YES YES WITH A MATURE
AND I APOLOGIZE I KNOW
EVERYBODY'S READY TO GO BUT I
JUST AGAIN WANT TO THANK THIS
COMMITTEE AND WENT THINK
GERMAN. AND ALL THE SUPPORT
THAT WE'VE HAD IN THIS MEASURE
AGAIN- IT'S AS STATED WITH
HISTORICAL INJUSTICE. THAT HAVE
LONG LASTING HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND THIS BILL WILL ALLOW US TO
CORRECT THAT IT DOESN'T
REPRESENT- COMPLETE CLOSURE TO
THIS ISSUE BUT IT REPRESENTS
OPPORTUNITY FOR THIS STATE.THE
ON DO AND IT JUST THAT WAS-
DONNING TO THE BRUCE FAMILY IN
THE SIX OTHER FAMILIES THAT.
WERE ON THIS LAND. AND THE CITY
OF MANHATTAN BEACH WITH COUNTY
LOS SENATORS AND THE STATE.
INHERITED THIS DATA- TO BE PAID
TO THE BRUCE. IF THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN MULTI MILLIONAIRES
UNDER ANY OTHER COND ADDITION
AND WOOD AFFORDED THEM
GENERATIONAL WEALTH THIS BILL
SIMPLY. ALLOWS THAT DATA- TO BE
PAID- NOT JUST PROMISED SO-
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF STATE
WHAT REPARATIONS GO LOOK LIKE
WITH JUSTICE LOOK LIKE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR THE CLOSING. A
LOCAL QUESTION. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA.
HI EDUARDO GARCIA I DALI. DALI
I'VE BEEN IT BIGELOW. BIGELOW
HI FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA I KALRA.
COLORADO LEVINE. LEVINE AYE
MURATSUCHI. NO ONE. KNEW WHEN I
RUBIO. RUBIO AYE SALAS. SMITH
SMITH I'D BE A PRODUCER. VIA
VIDEO AYE WARD WARD I. THANK
YOU LEAVE OPENED TO THE WEEKEND
TO GO BACK TO THE TOP AND I
CANNOT SHARE MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THAT WAS THE LAST
BILL WILL GO ALL THE WAY UP TO
THE TOP AG ARE FIVE. LUZ RIVAS
BILL FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON- AND
SECRETARY TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL NOT. I AM NUMBER ONE A. J.
R. FIVE ABSENT MEMBERS WE HAVE
TO DO A BIT DO I OKAY. THAT
BILL WITHOUT SB EIGHTY MCGUIRE.
ADAM NUMBER TWO S. B. EIGHTY
ABSENT MEMBERS WARD. WARD I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SB FOUR
SEVENTY. ABSENT MEMBERS KALRA.
WARD WARD I. SB FIVE FIVE NINE
TADO. ABSENT MEMBERS OF BENNETT.
KALRA MAYOR SEARCHING. SB SIX
TWO SIX. DODD ABSENT MEMBERS
BENNETT LEVINE. MERS SEARCHING
SALAS. SB. SEVEN NINETY. ABSENT
MEMBERS BENNETT LEVINE LEVINE I
MURATSUCHI SALAS. SB SEVEN NINE
SIX ABSENT MEMBERS BENNETT
MURATSUCHI SALAS. CONSENT
CALENDAR. ABSENT MEMBERS. THE A
PRODUCER. IT'S CALLED MEMBERS
KALRA AND SALAS TO SEE IF
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ADDING ON
TO THE LAST MEMBER OF. BILLS
AND- SB SIX TWO SIX SB SIX TWO
SIX ABSENT MEMBER LEVINE LEVINE
I. THAT BILLS OUT.
YEAH. SB SIX
TWO SIX ABSENT MEMBERS SALAS.
SALAS I. SB SEVEN NINETY ABSENT
MEMBERS SALAS SALAS I. SB SEVEN
NINE SIX ABSENT MEMBERS SALAS
SALAS I. THAT YOU'RE ON
EVERYTHING ELSE. FULLER LEAVE
THIS OPEN JUST FOR A FEW
MINUTES FOR ANOTHER MEMBER TO
ADD ON AND WILL CLOSE THIS OUT.
AFTER.
I THANK. NO WE'RE GONNA.